so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect what's up guys i am thomas
dobaziola whatever you want to call me
this is the dope usual podcast i am with
marty o'neal what's up folks what's up
guys this is another episode you guys
most of our guests are people you keep
asking to come on the show so once again
another guest that we're bringing
because you guys asked so much this is
hex hector rodriguez how are you doing
man i'm doing great thank you for uh
it's hot as hell outside did not realize
the temperature change between la and
the valley
oh yeah they don't know there's wind out
there is what it is yeah yeah um it is
for everyone out there we're in
california you're from texas and you're
telling me it's hot so yeah that must be
pretty hot yeah yeah it is you know what
i'm saying 100 it's a different kind of
hot though i i just moved to texas four
years ago originally from chicago spent
24 winters there
um and oh
no i promised that i was never going to
complain about it being too high because
of how cold i've been for so long that
like today is one of the first times in
i don't know a year that i've complained
about the heat because i never
complained about heat so you're from
chicago
born and raised no so i was born in el
paso texas so right on the border oh
really yeah my mom used to would be a
caretaker in 1980 that's when i was born
42 years old um
you're 42 yeah oh [ __ ] lucky ass full
looks yeah 28.
it never gets old
but but uh i was born in el paso in the
united states but i lived in juarez
mexico until 13 years old so okay went
to school there until seventh grade and
then eighth grade is when i moved to uh
wheeling illinois
what a move
they kidnapped me bro i they they they
asked me no hey would you want to live
in the united states yes it would have
been yeah right but they just grabbed me
and my sister my mom and my dad and they
said we're moving to
to uh to chicago and i was like cool
not knowing anything about it because
that's what my cousins used to tell me
back then uh but it was cold as [ __ ]
year one
and from there the 24 years that i was
there was
uh just like it didn't even matter cold
didn't matter it just became something
that you had to live with so it became
something but i got sick of it and i
told my wife one day i'm like we're
moving out of this [ __ ] place as soon
as we get a chance to and we got a
chance to so we did texas so you moved
back to texas yeah i never lived in
texas because i lived in on the mexico
side but
yeah yeah homies in el paso i'm supposed
to go there soon actually i've never
been but he's like yeah look
mexico
america he's right on the border bro i'm
telling you when you go
rafa's burritos
and uh taco totes my spots yeah i mean
there's everyone spots but those are
ones that i frequent every single time
well i mean that's always good that's
always good advice man because i'm going
and i'm just like
what am i going to do here it's my homie
listen here's some restaurants yeah yeah
it's one of my best friends so i have to
go yeah i have family in el paso i've
never met
a lot actually that's where grandpa's
from
um
so you're going from mexico to chicago
yeah but in the 80s or early night yeah
no 93 yeah so michael jordan's still
there oh yeah yeah and from the
beginning because we had family in
chicago michael jordan was or the bulls
were our team uh my dad loved the uh
celtics back in the day i mean obviously
he came from a different era but for me
it was always michael from the beginning
and to this day i have his back he is
the greatest time oh he is the greatest
of all time period undisputed
you can argue that's fine oh there's
always going to be an argument yeah it's
like what if they all played against
each other like well he's 20 years older
i'm going to tell you different i'm
going to tell you one data point that no
one has ever considered about michael
jordan what makes him even
better okay
that dude competed
in these at a professional level do you
know how uncomfortable
every single [ __ ] pair of jordan says
it is the most uncomfortable shoe ever
but still people wear it right to play
ball in it this dude was playing like
so he's so good that he's like yo i'm
gonna make money wearing these
uncomfortable ass shoes i swore off
jordan's last year because
i see that crease day one i'm like are
you [ __ ] kidding me i'mma throw up
yeah i can't do this no more bro now
we're he's been crazy so
i wear vans my whole life but jordan's
i'm like you know what heartbreak too
many times yeah it's there's only so
much you could do i know i know you know
what i'm talking about man yeah i wear
them i don't care i'm like crease no
crease i don't give a [ __ ] i feel you
but i just remember looking at cause you
know when you grow up i did you grew up
with uh i mean you grew up in mexico you
guys probably didn't grow up with a
bunch of money if you're moving just
like that i [ __ ] on a bucket at one
point you know growing up oh yeah yeah
so it was uh no humble beginnings for me
super super humble beginnings yeah it
just hurts my heart no matter how much
money you make i'm like dude i'm not
gonna increase brand new jays yeah it's
like here's some weed throw it out oh
[ __ ] but also nike figure that [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out it's like
40 years into this [ __ ] put some extent
put some [ __ ] mesh something
200
yeah dude um
so question you're growing up in mexico
until you're 13 years old so do you are
you guys
are you fluent with english or do you
have to earn learn when you get here so
when i got here i i understood a little
bit of english because of cartoons right
so everything that was being broadcasted
in el paso that's how people learn it
was crazy it was being broadcasted in in
mexico and that's how i got a little bit
of uh of the understanding but it took
me about six months to lose to learn
english six an additional six months to
lose my accent or as much of it as as i
could now the reason was because was
because i was in esl english i'm sure
you guys know here in california um
you'd be surprised how many people don't
know about esl uh anyway uh i just
didn't want to be
ever be put in a position to where i was
gonna be embarrassed you know like the
fear the anxiety of being embarrassed
because i can't defend myself right
because if somebody's coming at me
trying to make fun of me in uh in
english how the [ __ ] am i going to be
funny and roast assassins you know if i
can't get back at it
i get you this is opposite for me yeah i
everybody in my family is from mexico
spoke speak spanish fluently except for
me
because my mom doesn't speak spanish i
grew up with her okay and she's first
generation so you're second no uh my mom
was my mom was a jewish lady oh she was
born oh god my dad my dad's
every cousin i ever had i'm at the table
going what the [ __ ] you guys talking
about yeah you guys go to school me just
tell me in english yeah and nobody ever
taught me they just made fun of me yeah
so it was the opposite for me like you
guys making fun of me yeah i can't roast
you it's like you said what the opposite
yeah if i was you if i was you i would i
would have i would have been more
conniving i would have been like all
right cool yeah i'm going to take it but
then when you get in public
you know in an american setting then you
you start you know they speak english
too oh they did too so they were just oh
god damn they never taught me yeah yeah
yeah so i was that kid but at school
like i like i got i moved too i moved to
oregon and bro
everyone said you speak english like are
you [ __ ] kidding me man yeah i just
said dude to you yeah i don't speak
spanish
wild yeah yeah so you don't speak any
spanish still still to say i mean i
talked to my grandma and grandpa i'm
like you guys could teach me anytime
yeah
but i talked to marty i need to [ __ ]
learn bro marty you speak spanish [ __ ]
no no no he's from new york yeah
you'd never get yeah no but trent my
whitest friend with the longest blonde
hair ever speaks fluent spanish i just
need someone to teach me man i think
where does he work he lives in hawaii uh
wow he's from fresno though
yeah my daughter who's 12 years old she
um she's very fluent in both right we
made it a point from the beginning her
grandma took care of her growing up too
when we were built when i was building
optic and my wife was supporting us by
going to work um like yeah she she grew
up there so she only spoke spanish to
her is your wife's uh spanish too yeah
she's mexican yeah
okay so
she's for uh second gen well not no
she's first generation but she was born
in chicago
where i was born in i possibly lived in
mexico she never lived in mexico maybe
for like one there's a lot of mexican
people in chicago right oh yeah yeah
massively i had to ask i had no idea uh
fernando yabara shout out to you from
mexico one of our fans he's like dude
that's a huge mexican community massive
bro there's more mexicans than anything
else how i don't know what the [ __ ] is
nobody talking about
like like ready like new york who do you
see in new york puerto ricans yeah
puerto ricans are dominicans 100 always
puerto ricans is the right answer right
in in chicago it's mexicans there are
puerto ricans there are dominicans and
there are but mexicans
mexican polish
uh are like the the the majority what
the [ __ ] in chicago yeah
mass i mean obviously there's like
korean children i get that but if that's
the main yeah
ethnicity that's [ __ ] quick my school
was [ __ ] dope wheeling illinois in
high school shout out to to them uh
the the first day is story time right
now but i wasn't smoking back then i was
a [ __ ] straight edge were you growing
up yeah like what age were you still
straight aged uh 17 was the first uh
first time i i smart
thank you one of those you got one yeah
i got one whenever you run out i got
these thank you thank you i also brought
you some presents and we'll get to them
after the story line or the story time
go for it so first this is like the to
give people an idea of what it was like
in like early 90s i'm talking about 1994
1994 i'm i'm a freshman first day of
school there's a school assembly right
and all of a sudden a [ __ ] fight
breaks out right at the assembly at the
assembly day one the the the teacher and
the in the what are they called uh
administrators principals yeah all of
them they were they were they were in
the middle of the of the basketball
court giving a speech some black dude
or this mexican dude that we used to
know rest in peace he passed away but
this dude throws uh a paper at the group
black dudes that were to the right of us
so they turned around they start talking
[ __ ] so these mexicans that i'm [ __ ]
and i'm sitting there with uh by myself
and a couple of friends and i'm like day
one day one i'm from i'm like fresh off
one year in the united states so all of
this like racism i didn't know it
existed i didn't know that people
weren't going to like me because of the
skin of it i didn't know that right i
was i mean born in mexico everyone's the
same why would you be racist yeah
exactly right or just period right
anyway so i get there and then they're
like
apparently at the time the blacks the
mexicans weren't getting along
apparently right so sure enough
it was like a like a like a [ __ ]
uh uh mudslide boom everybody hits the
hit and not because of the color because
of the movement all right but
the other way bro
so everybody goes in and they start
fighting bro and i'm like holy [ __ ] and
i'm thinking to myself i'm like am i
going to get [ __ ] punched
by a [ __ ] sophomore junior dude like
a big black dude just because
so i'm like i'm sitting back and i'm
just like
like literally with my hands up like
this right i'm what 14 at the time right
i have been in fights but in mexico not
no fights over here and my dad was very
strict right he said no
fighting no getting in trouble like
no no time for that
so this fight [ __ ] breaks out and it
was the wildest [ __ ] i've ever seen
i've never seen violence like that until
there right like i've experienced
violence because i grew up in mexico
obviously uh you know
cartels which i don't i don't talk about
but all that stuff like it was that but
this was like right in front of my face
saw this uh this black dude get kicked
in the back with with some pointy-ass
mexican boots from a big mexican oh the
worst yeah big mexican dude kicked him
in the back right in the spine and i'm
like oh like i lost my breath i'm like
oh like it like i felt that dude's pain
some teachers tried to get involved and
they were getting flung like old ladies
were just getting flung out to size boom
boom boom bro
it broke out into the foyer into the
trophy room it was [ __ ] up but that
was my
my experience experience yeah the one
the most memorable one for sure
so
my mom got my mom almost broke her neck
like that a kid came up and booted her
in the [ __ ] neck she was breaking up
a fight in a school and that like for
the rest of her life yeah at that moment
no yeah
yeah kids are wild and then now that i
think about now that you're older and
i'm older i think back and oh you have a
lighter right there too if you need it
right here um kids are violent as [ __ ]
yeah now that i remember i wasn't
because i'm the same person as a kid but
yeah you know you i guarantee you have
homies like yo remember how wild your
ass used to be you used to be a [ __ ]
monster now they're like oh i'm a dad
and i work at [ __ ] them yes i was
never a monster no i know i didn't see
those people though yeah it's a trick
because i see my friends that used to be
[ __ ] hoodlums and now there's just
fathers and it's the weirdest [ __ ] as i
get older to see that yeah
yeah anyway so
the reason i brought that fight up is
because i didn't by that time i hadn't
fully
understood and was able to communicate
in english
so for me to tell somebody i'm not
involved in this thing i'm i'm [ __ ]
innocent don't [ __ ]
punch me i was like i got to learn
english
oh that was a turning point yeah well no
i mean i was like already in the process
i'm like how am i gonna talk to girls
you know what i'm saying like you know
so that's where art became a big part of
my life there too right like i started
drawing people's names girls names to
break the ice and [ __ ] hey
that's how i caught it that's how i
recorded my wife you know [ __ ]
romantic ass kid don't speak english
here
i swallowed girls i didn't speak english
but i did speak the language of love
let's go
i bet you it worked pretty well oh yes
there's the easiest uh icebreaker ever i
was like hey i made something for you it
came from my brain to my hand to this
piece of paper
take [ __ ] notes guys texting in your
dick pics don't work right yeah draw her
name
at least hide it a little bit or do it
if you're dressing it up you know what i
mean if you put a bow what a tie if i
was if i was
you know in my youth and you know dick
pic sharing was a thing like i think i
would dress it up you know what i mean i
would make it more of a funny thing
yeah something like a little sombrero
google eyes no yeah little google eyes
right but i i would also give it a
holster you know what i mean with the
little piston shirt
something i wouldn't just send it out on
like is it is it well kept is the first
thing that i would do right
is it you know what what are what are
some areas that need to work right it's
like what's that little pimple doing
there oh my god what's she gonna think
that is what you're gonna think that is
jesus christ we went there right yeah
it's okay i take left turns all the time
it's fine dude you take four of them and
you're back to where you started yeah um
nascar [ __ ] first off
oh wait [ __ ] nascar first off why
because it's just taken left so boring
to me yeah
what about f1 that's just scary as [ __ ]
that's too cool but is it because you
watch the documentary or is it because
you just like f1 i've never seen a
documentary
i've only watched f1 on netflix and [ __ ]
oh you don't watch you don't watch
you're not a tv consumer no i don't
really watch uh i watch sci-fi
the [ __ ] oh no i'm not he's the
[ __ ] cable guy yes cable guy but
not to [ __ ] that doesn't like sports and
stuff
it's cool but not nascar i can't watch
racing but that's what [ __ ] is amazing
this one's going 200 miles an hour yeah
lifting off the ground sometimes yeah
yeah i'll watch about five minutes of it
and i'm like i'll watch the rest on the
highlights but at that point is a
concentration more than more than
athleticism
i think to hold that steering wheel like
that you got to be a pretty popeye
foreign [ __ ] man yeah because
i've held my car in my car i'm like
what if you're going 200. yes you're
right out there yeah
thank you but you know what i mean like
you have to have [ __ ]
jacked ass forearms yeah you see those
insides these fools are smashing around
yeah the [ __ ] that gets me have you ever
seen uh
the fools that can't see when the rally
cars they can't see they have a
navigator telling them what to turn no
the guy can't see the road up come
because you're gonna want someone
playing video games with with a real
life person 100 the guy sitting next to
him i left uh 45 degrees and the guy was
just i watched the rally
is that a real thing it's a real thing
because the guy's driving and he he
knows the course but you're going 150 on
a [ __ ] dirt road in france so they're
flying through towns i never [ __ ]
knew that you ever see the little like
uh the little subarus that are [ __ ]
flying yeah that's that there's two
dudes because one tells them are left in
six seconds go it's no insane bro i
gotta i got i gotta do i gotta i gotta
fact check you on that because that
sounds just watch ludicrous i like i
said i watch youtube compilations
seinfeld in the office that's pretty
much
all my expertise listen in my ten years
of youtube i've done some blind you know
competitions in which you're the one
navigating and the other ones the one
like you know doing it
so driving is just like seems like an
impossible thing they're going hundreds
120 yeah in a cage right obviously so
like there's a level of safety there but
gas is liquid not really gas is liquid
smoke you know like people don't like
all of this [ __ ] that goes into my head
when i'm like
if there's a crash what if like for some
reason the car ends up being on top but
it's the tail end of it so all of the
smog from of course
and i'm like
not the kind of smoke i want to die no
exactly i would that would be the worst
bro
you watched you watched final
destination a lot yeah not a lot but i
watched all of them i watched it a lot
and uh that [ __ ] gives it makes me
cautious
like i don't do do you [ __ ] with teslas
no i mean
would you [ __ ] with them would you get
one i don't have one now i think they're
scary yeah because i mean one of the
doors don't open we're just like yo i'm
gonna keep going 120 [ __ ] your brakes
yeah [ __ ] malfunctions my computer
crashes sometimes oh no i don't think i
don't think that that one would though i
think that i would i do have faith in it
i've i've experienced tesla auto
the self driving like before tesla
became even [ __ ] popular there was
this dude named uh [ __ ]
james
oh god he's gonna he doesn't he won't
watch this james if you're out there uh
he had a tesla and we were here in la
and this was like a a film producer and
he had a tesla and i got in and he said
watch this [ __ ] puts it on auto and i'm
like get the [ __ ] out of here the car
does the the turn onto the off ramp and
then on to the next one on its own and
it was early days and i'm like [ __ ] i
remember making a story of it back this
had to have been
2013 2014 like early early early on
before all the all the other [ __ ]
but yeah i i would trust that i don't
have one but i would trust it
oh no man
you seem like a like a pickup truck type
of dude i have a pickup truck it's a
ford f-150
but i only bought it because i bought a
fishing boat oh nice uh-huh are you like
an outdoorsman i used to be not since
video games i became a little bit more
of an endorsement
yeah so you didn't grow up a gamer no i
was [ __ ] up no hell no that's the 90s
basically literally the next question
you didn't grow up a [ __ ] game right
now
no no no no i was no bro [ __ ]
basketball football soccer
sports is what i grew up for sure right
girls sports fun nice graffiti
partying no no drugs no no liquor though
so boring good [ __ ] though no no you got
the good parts because those always make
you [ __ ] the night up drinking and drugs
always [ __ ] the night up in the end
yeah yeah but i do have a pickup truck
but i uh
yeah i like i like a four by fours
oh you're texas i've never been on a
four-wheeler i've never done anything
i've done all that [ __ ] yeah i've never
once done it ever and it looks fun as
hell if you if you ever come out listen
if you ever come out to texas i'll take
you to uh one of my business partners
has uh a massive ranch in okc wheat's
legal we can go fishing we can go
off-roading you can see his giraffes his
zebras and [ __ ] yeah this dude's bro
this dude owns land as far as the eye
can see texas sounds awesome it's just
the weed laws are scary man dude
sucks [ __ ] scary dude like hey yeah
no yeah automatic take it to mcdonald's
[ __ ] that joke yes oh come on man yeah
and it'd be cool if they gave you a
ticket you know what i mean
yeah the fact that they take you to jail
is like [ __ ] mommy's just [ __ ] up
he's going through trial right now over
some weed
i got caught with the same amount they
went oh you got your card yeah where
where oh [ __ ] yeah yeah i stayed in
austin a couple months and it just
turned me off to the whole [ __ ] place
like yeah bastards are gonna have willie
nelson out here represent your city and
then put people in [ __ ] jail for this
[ __ ] yeah
the [ __ ] up thing is is that the
majority of the population in texas is
cool with it they're ready
they're ready
but
it is the
the government that that's like still
they still haven't decided who's going
to be the one that makes money and how
do they make the money exactly and until
they figure that piece out this won't be
legalized in eight minutes
give me a piece of paper it's simple
it's [ __ ] simple taxes
no
no no no you didn't get what i was
saying it's not how the government makes
money that would get taxes to help the
people in its population yeah no it's
the politicians yeah who haven't figured
out how they're gonna make money gotcha
if they pass this [ __ ] law they just
buy the companies if if you're if you're
uh if you're a security guard outside a
club you're i'm not gonna just let you
in you've got paper pop first so you
think you think you think that 100 bucks
goes to the club no that goes to the
[ __ ] security guard
yeah all right besides that's really
good and now everything's simple it
always goes back to [ __ ] money and
just [ __ ] basically yeah
i think it's kind of wild though because
you know some of these politicians got a
couple hundred mil stash
i don't know if i could be greedy still
at that point it'd be kind of odd what
depends are you looking at it as a game
or are you looking at it as a as a means
to live the life that you want to live
is that a competition like i think
competitions will fix people up yeah
like you know my home we got a boat yeah
well [ __ ] man he's got a yacht my wife
thinks he's cooler i don't know that's
what i think rich guys think yeah i
don't know how i don't know i don't know
you know like pieces of [ __ ] in movies
yeah like those guys yeah how do they
think i don't think like a rich dude
like american psycho like american
psycho dudes exactly
just giving a [ __ ] about their next
[ __ ] business card and like now i'm
gonna kill this [ __ ] yeah yeah
um so
you did not grow up a gamer how did you
get into this because
it's not like you just you played some
games and now you're like yo i do twitch
i feel like gamer isn't the right word
for him
yeah i was gonna say so i i'm in the
video game industry uh we didn't do an
introduction to me so for those of you
who don't know me i own a team called
optic gaming it's uh it was like the the
first of its kind from it many many
different clans have derived from it
face clan hunter thieves all these other
things but uh so 100 teams specifically
their ceo is one of my closest friends
ever he used to be on my team played for
my team he and i you know built
something great together right called
optic
and everybody else that saw this
obviously there but you know i mean like
he was one of the main popular ones uh
gaming
as fun as it is if you guys play call of
duty there are competitions right and
they are competitions for a lot of money
now back in the day it was like you know
2011 was the first time that there was
ever a million dollar tournament for
call of duty
how many people are on a team
for 250 for each [ __ ] player yeah and
the org didn't take a cut of that
because i was nice i was building
something bigger but so you had your own
team you're letting them keep the money
they're just repping you guys yeah i
mean we were all see that's the thing
nowadays this wrapping is not the same
thing as repping back in the day right
back in the day when you were part of
the team like in the 90s if you're part
of a gang you you
you're repping that because of something
bigger it's not just something that you
know it's not a sponsor right like like
nowadays there's a lot of uh influencers
and a lot of uh uh
people that just
are sponsored by their teams no not
necessarily brand deals but they're just
sponsored by your team they don't belong
to an actual team right my people belong
to this team like there's a sense of
culture and the ones that are successful
have those those same cultures right uh
the face class like you can tell there's
a family there of friends that [ __ ]
you know was there to create something
bigger
under thieves and all these other ones
uh there's a lot of good ones the bigger
ones have that sense of
of uh of family before business because
they turned into a business at one point
so i was chill with goblin and eric
oh that [ __ ] sounded crazy yeah that's a
new mic god damn i mad um i was chilling
with them about a month ago and they
told me what clans were
i don't really play games yeah yeah
i didn't know
that there's teams like i didn't know
what the [ __ ] phase was i didn't know
when anything that's crazy and you
you've been on youtube for how long
eight years yeah see the thing is that
you had to have come across some people
see the word phase yeah yeah yeah i've
seen that but i thought it was like a
[ __ ] like a like a group of homies
like this the hype house thing so you
know where people are yeah we all made
content i didn't know they were [ __ ]
gaming and they're good as [ __ ] at it
yeah well yeah i mean i think it was
more like the the the face clan boys the
the way that we were were just about
content and being good enough to be
entertaining right the rest of it was
gonna be carried by your personality um
some professional gamers are not
necessarily that
but gaming has influenced youtube like
you've never seen before and your
channel for example unfortunately
doesn't have the ability to be monetized
because of this and it's not youtube
it's more of the advertisers doing that
but uh you in the past like
when i started doing youtube you could
not monetize your own channel the way
that i can today yeah it was because of
of certain gaming
legal
because you're showing their game no not
necessarily that no i'm talking about
just just uh the ability for one human
self to be able to monetize their
youtube channel that system never
existed until gaming came along and was
able to sort of say some something set
the precedence essentially the the
precedence essentially to be able to
monetize your own channel because at one
point you had to submit your work
to a network for them to monetize it on
their channel they would take their cut
and then they would give you your money
so everything you say today was like
everything that you see on youtube today
is influenced by gaming gaming changes
is that because twitch was doing it or
is that nice before which came after
yeah
yeah twitch came after it came after
they started doing the whole just after
youtube and just just in general it was
like twitch is younger
and
although twitch
so although twitch can never be youtube
because of the vod programming and all
that stuff uh
youtube can do live they're doing live
now right like i do youtube live yeah
yeah but i mean
i did i just thought it was always there
no dude no no at one point you couldn't
make money for youtube you know like and
let alone
you make money on your youtube channel
on you know for your own is [ __ ]
crazy yeah that's like saying hey i'm an
uber driver but i just submit my [ __ ] at
the end of the day and i hope i get paid
i mean i think that's what they do right
i have no idea is that really how it
works
although they got paid right away yeah
because they don't they go uh i pay uber
and then uber pays them right oh yeah i
thought they were just getting it right
away yeah yeah but
so you could not so gaming is
essentially responsible for all the
logan paul's of the world
not necessarily like the way they get
paid and yeah oh yeah they had a major
play in it for sure multi-channel
networks didn't exist until or existed
but not in terms of
i'm gonna monetize your channel also
right so back in the day to give an
example back in the day there will be a
group of people that have a business
called machinima and that's just an
example have you heard of machinima okay
so machinima was the end-all-be-all
greatest youtube brand for gaming ever
the first of its kind
uh
ask [ __ ]
a sick thing so they could only they
they went to youtube and they say hey we
have our own sales team
we would like to sell ads against this
thing so youtube is like okay cool since
this is our platform we're gonna take
the 40
and then you guys do whatever the [ __ ]
you guys want with with the rest of the
money um
so they were like okay cool so this
these are our channels this is these
three right machinima machinima sports
and machinima whatever the [ __ ] else
right it wasn't until gaming
personality started to say hey i want to
upload more videos to your channel so i
can monetize that the conversation
started to happen to be like
all right now they are going to be like
hey i also have this channel
and then cool we'll monetize that we'll
plug it into the system blah blah cool
well imagine that times 10 000
right so that this system sort of had to
be developed in order for that to happen
and up until one point it wasn't youtube
was the only people making money it
wasn't until somebody came in and
started to say hey we have our own sales
team i didn't know that
so gaming pretty much allowed people
allowed youtube to give the push to say
it played a big part to pay everybody it
paid a big part because of the the size
of the community that was there
originally right if you think about back
in the day it was all about comedic
skits right the
um what were they called i don't even
remember but long story short because i
had the size of the community of
creators in the gaming space that they
had to figure out a way to monetize all
of that opportunity
right because if they're uploading
five videos a day on one specific
channel times three
imagine how much money they were making
back then right where the cpms had to
have been whatever the [ __ ] they wanted
them to be as long as they paid youtube
their thing so in their heads like well
if we can upload not just
i don't know uh 15 videos a day and make
150 000 a month what happens if we
multiply that times 10 000 channels
you know what i mean so you sort of
start to develop this business and this
business model and then youtube's like
well why the [ __ ] am i allowing these
networks to be the only ones that can do
that why don't we just plug them into
our own adsense which is what you see
today
that was great bro i didn't even know
that i might i may have made all that
[ __ ] up right now
[Laughter]
you [ __ ] convince me man
so what what are you smoking on
this is uh oh gee i just smoke koji all
the time let me can if there's one yeah
og kush yeah
um so
like i said earlier i i will say joseph
was like you know how you get when you
smoke the ogs what happens you get tired
i get [ __ ] i get naked
i'm kidding that's looking to l.a to
strip
because you know la is og bro i mean
right now it's a lot of commercial
commercial wii like a lot of flavors but
i mean this is
where it's from i mean this is not where
it's from this is where it's popularized
you know because i'm i'm up from up
north and i immediately got high oh [ __ ]
and i'm high as [ __ ] yeah i wish man i
[ __ ] i smoke it all day every day but
there'll be sometimes i smoke as a team
with somebody and go oh my god what is
this feeling
ah i'm good you're gonna liked it for a
minute and go i'd just rather get [ __ ]
up immediately yeah
i don't know there's something about an
og smoke
right when you like catch it and you
blow it out it's like damn that's a film
i was like
and i just love that [ __ ] oh
it gets me hyped yeah
my my favorite right now is chem driver
that's like the oh sunday driver in
camden yeah yeah kendall's good man yeah
i i've i've only gotten like five real
packs of chem in my life
and it grows so weird it's finicky but
it grows so uh
[ __ ] oh it's got nubs on it and it's
got like
like tumors it looks like it's [ __ ]
weird but it's tumors
like who doesn't want to smoke tumors
you know what i mean it looks like it's
got lumps all over its [ __ ] little
hands that's what it is it looks like a
little tree but with [ __ ] hands all
over it yeah
so i'm sorry before i keep getting in
too far into weed because i know we'll
keep going yeah
real quick you for me i told you earlier
i didn't know about clans i didn't know
there was teams i i saw i knew people
played madden for money because my homie
does that [ __ ] mommy plays like the
world champion uh street fighter
competition on [ __ ] the joysticks
yeah i've seen that that's [ __ ] tight
you guys made a team or you made a team
and then just said the call of duty
there's a competition we're gonna go
play oh worse what it was worse the way
that i did it now i didn't just create a
team and i created a team of only
snipers
only the only weapon you can use was
sniping there's the m483 that you see
right there
are you [ __ ] serious oh [ __ ] this is
deep in the call of duty yeah i love
it's changed my life
so it was just call of duty you guys
play you don't play any other game at
first yeah at first it was call of duty
so let me let me tell you the the the
optics strategy the optic book and why
it it it all leads down to all roads
lead to optical god damn it um
you know what i was doing right there i
wasn't cleaning i was just like it was
just my idiosyncrasies being
idiosyncrasies
i do it a lot too but i was like i don't
want him to have to think he has to
clean it up
you know what i've been doing you know
what i've been stopping myself from
doing and i just i just did it right now
i cover i cover it my hand always goes
up here every time yeah it's just like
uh but there's no [ __ ] wind in here i
do it no matter just like
every time i never you'll never see me
do it like this unless i'm just hot and
rambling yeah every time yeah i don't
know why it's because someone's got i
think you like this i think i like
looking you know what you can start to
you know what it is it's a long long
long
just
process of brainwashing that you get as
a little kid when you're about to blow
your candles you have your little
cousins and you know they're trying to
blow out your candles so what you do
nowadays is you're lucky
yeah you block your [ __ ] you're not
going to stop me from letting my candle
making my [ __ ] wish ptsd yeah exactly
yeah so anyway
and blew out a candle i never had no
[ __ ]
goddammit
yo what's up guys taking a minute to
talk about one of our sponsors and this
is miller lite before we get into any of
this guys do me a favor go to
millerlight.com forward slash yola and
that's going to take you to a landing
page of every single place in your area
that will deliver milo light to your
house or like we always say you can go
to any store on earth that sells miller
lite and just grab it right there and we
say it every single time do not drink
and drive please be responsible you got
to be 21 or older don't be dumb so
milwaukee wisconsin the milwaukee
brewing company guys please celebrate
responsibly and once again i say it
every time it's 96 calories 3.2 grams of
carbs for every single can
guys for this ad read marty and i did
something a little special something a
little different i know it's just an
this is an ad read in the middle of the
show but we wanted to just say thank you
to miller light say thank you to you
everybody out there that's supporting us
was that's why we're able to do this so
thank you guys for making it possible
and thank you to miller light for making
everything else possible so you saw a
sneak peek of this on our instagram but
this is the full thing guys thank you so
much for being here let it play
[Music]
hey what's up everybody i'm dopaziola
and this is the dope as usual podcast
and we just want to take a minute to
talk about miller lite
as you guys are already aware marty now
the dope as usual podcast we are the
2022 brand ambassadors to miller lite
for all the legal drinking age fans out
there and i know there's a lot if you're
going to drink beer drink miller lite
knowing that it's supporting your
favorite show as i said before what does
miller lite remind me of it reminds me
of some of the best times of my life and
you guys know that me and my uncle john
this was our beer this is bringing back
every time i drink it it floods back
memories in the backyard bonfire playing
basketball miller lite to me brings back
good times it brings back nostalgia of
just fun not to mention i'm not a huge
beer drinker and i like miller light one
of the very few beers i can actually
drink without going
no matter which episode it is no matter
what guess what topic the thing marty
and i stressed before we even got the
miller light deal we stress all the time
don't drink and drive don't be stupid
don't hurt yourself or somebody else
thank you guys so much for supporting
our show marty and i still it's unreal
to us every time guys from backyards to
billboards here we are miller lite
milwaukee wisconsin milwaukee brewing
company
it's miller time
so yeah so uh in call of duty there were
already teams that were competing
against each other right money no yeah
for sometimes for money it was just word
of mouth at the time
so what we did is like my brother and i
uh my brother 10 years younger than me
um at the time he was like 16 i was like
[ __ ] wait 26 27 yeah he was like 17
right whatever um
we just like sniping for me sniping was
always like the baddest soldier ever the
one on the cover shooting from far as
[ __ ] away and uh and everything in my
life forever and always has been about
you know being accurate right like uh
when i was playing football like i
wanted to be the best quarterback there
[ __ ] was so i practiced every single
pitching
i practiced [ __ ] all of that throwing
was my [ __ ] being accurate was my [ __ ]
you're a photographer too right uh yeah
oh yeah same thing yeah yeah same idea
yeah exactly yeah getting the shot boom
so as i'm as i'm going through through
life and and liking these like war
movies and liking the sniper right like
growing up the [ __ ] i finally found a
game that had a good sniping thing on it
was call of duty 2. right so we started
playing that uh and then
you know we found out about what
competition was so we started competing
it was these four before word of mouth
[ __ ] uh being popular on a website
40 teams maybe or whatever
um but that developed into something
bigger very quickly right when when when
uh when we switched over to call of duty
4 when call of duty 4 came out we had
the idea of let's just snipe we're just
going to be snipers we're not going to
use any other [ __ ] weapon in the
world we're just going to [ __ ] use
snipers and that's it that's the rule
why because it's the baddest [ __ ]
scope i'm gonna shoot one weapon i'ma
kill you before you kill me with your
15 to 30 bullets so i was gonna do
i was gonna shoot one bullet every three
seconds and they were gonna
try to kill me with a [ __ ] instant
barrage of bullets anyway
in the game you can develop that the
quick scope and ability to have you ever
played video games i [ __ ] with call of
duty okay so you know what quick quick
scope on this yeah when you just shoot a
[ __ ] when it goes it pops up
so so optic was the first of its kind
sniper team ever
really because of optic so the clips
i've seen are you guys i mean yeah i
mean it's like by now by now by now
there's millions of stuff because i've
seen it on youtube years ago yeah i've
seen i've seen a competition yeah so so
my team was the first sniper team ever
like the the the the the concept of
sniping teams didn't exist
so from optic
came phase
uh soar and all these other like like
but face obviously being like the most
popular one because it's the most
popular one today
not just in in in call of duty just in
in all of esports right um
an optic at the time was that right we
were the creme de la creme
[ __ ] baddest of the bad uh
so yeah we started sniping and little by
little the popularity of these videos
started to become big enough to where
people who were already running
competitive video games with
counter-strike uh
whatever uh they started to see this
thing and they're like all right well we
can probably monetize this [ __ ] too so
then halo started to become a thing
and then that halo and call of duty sort
of came up at the same time but they
were paying more attention to halo
because they had the superstars right
the first influencers that were bigger
than just your regular gaming
dude that's somewhere somewhere i've
never heard of i didn't i have no idea
there was a little community like that
bro it's [ __ ] crazy it's [ __ ] what
year is this yeah that's my next yes
it's like a
2009 2009 2010 2011. i was just how old
were you that how old are you today i'm
32 32. i was selling packs that's why i
probably didn't pay yeah
yeah yeah i didn't grow up playing video
games either i wasn't selling packs i
wasn't even smoking packs but i liked
video games still yeah i had madden call
of duty and um and gta is the only three
games i ever owned
every time they come out the new one
i'll get that yeah yeah so anyway
because of the popularity on youtube we
were there because we were having fun
[ __ ] that you got to think about it
like this i'm 29 years old right i
worked in corporate america by i was i
was i was in the matrix for about 10
years before i discovered the power of
youtube
right before the before finding on you
you could even make a like the second
that i knew that i could make two
dollars
on a video
i was like i'm never gonna do anything
else for the rest of my life now i have
i have a house right i'm 29 years old my
daughter just came into this world like
you have another career yeah i literally
had a career like i i was a corporate
dude i was like you know the usually
white collar dude [ __ ] suits during
the day oh [ __ ] graffiti during the
night
hey uh the the drinks are outside or i
ordered us some smoothies i hope you
don't mind no no you're only drinking
water nowadays all right i'm
trying is that did i see that somewhere
like because i saw your gym out there
and i and i know that you've been trying
to [ __ ] get into that [ __ ] oh i mean
i drink
i just drink a lot of water i don't
really drink it yeah nothing else not
really just juices and [ __ ] if i get
them bro water to me i i drink the
majority of my water intake at night
through the night i'll drink like
[ __ ] a liter of water through the
night no that's my my wife was like that
was this weirdest [ __ ] ever oh you like
wake up just start chugging but i'm like
chugging water like chugging water for
like [ __ ] 15 seconds like [ __ ]
just [ __ ] filling myself up during
the day i'll maybe three bottles if that
uh anyway where the [ __ ] were we
hydration no we were talking about a
clan talking about no you were in
corporate america
and then you're like i made two dollars
i ain't doing [ __ ] yeah never i'm never
gonna do anything else so that's when
the optic dream began and that's when we
were just like all right we if we're
going to do this let's do this let's be
cooler let's be different let's do this
and sniping made it harder on yourself
to get high scores and to win games
because you're
you know so that's where the level of
skill and competition came from but
because of the viewership is where i was
going people paid attention to
to call of duty because of optic from a
competitive level
if i was to [ __ ] tell you the rest of
it is just a bunch of like
fortunate events that led to the texas
rangers wanting to buy my my team for
yeah optic for [ __ ]
you know some crazy [ __ ] crazy crazy
figures the texas rangers base
let me rephrase that the owners of the
texas rangers not the texas right oh
okay so the owners saw you guys said hey
this is so popular on youtube i bet you
one of their sons watched it or
something it's like where how come how
come young people aren't coming here no
more it's what they were saying to
themselves it's like all we see is
[ __ ] old heads [ __ ] parents and
babies but where are the teenagers where
are the young adults well they're
consuming content here and what's on
here
digital sports what's the digital sport
i was like well [ __ ] people trying to
beat each other in a video game
um
so yeah so it was so big in the pub i
mean i'm gonna put you like this right
in chicago where we started optic and we
did there was only one sports team that
had a bigger social media following than
us and it was only because they had god
playing for them in the 90s okay the
chicago bulls and at the time that i
sold my team the chicago bulls had 4
million followers on twitter we had 3.4
million on twitter on twitter okay also
optic gaming is huge video games are the
biggest thing besides weed video games
are the the second biggest next to music
on youtube oh i'm not even talking about
i'm talking about in people's life right
now people like oh i game i [ __ ]
smoke
most people like i go to concerts it's
not like that i hear gaming smoking
[ __ ] weed or cars
hence the reason i am here today sir
let me tell you about pine park no i'm
kidding uh
but yeah it's massive it's a massive
industries there's the biggest
entertainment uh uh what is it [ __ ]
space genre genre and entertainment were
you guys on camera during that time or
was it just the gameplay footage just
the gameplay footage [ __ ] so you just
sat there and you talked over and you
were talking about stories you were
story time you were you were hearing
that [ __ ] just people telling about
their day
while playing the game yeah it's like oh
and i'm going to this spot because look
at the traffic and
i learned about this with that it was
even a thing through goblin i didn't
know surprised me yeah god
showed me goblin
like a month and a half yeah
and i didn't know about i didn't know
there was [ __ ] teams uh going out
[ __ ]
you're watching football team oh it's
okay okay appreciate it though all right
well i bought a bunch give some to my
man right there and then the other ones
you guys can have the uh
it's like it's like a actual basketball
team going out and getting prep wearing
the same shirts going in and [ __ ]
[ __ ] up face clan just got a billion
dollar value
eric let me in on that and i went hold
on did you say with a b
oh [ __ ]
so there's ten of them right he said
uh i mean yeah yeah of dudes in the clan
and that get to split that they
essentially got it i know but i don't
think i'm allowed to discuss it on my
team oh no but i'm saying like in
general if they got a billion dollars
for their team
everyone got paid like that because they
had such a good i mean i'm sure i'm sure
that there was a prior investment into
into their thing so like that that would
get paid off first before they see any
of that and it's also them exercising
options if they you know
because there was like a it was a spak
which uh which means that it's publicly
traded which means that their shares et
cetera so i think they may be like i
don't know there's a lock up period
where you can't sell your shares i don't
[ __ ] know but still come from years
ago to that yeah hearing billion
it's insane it's [ __ ] insane so sorry
well the owners of texas ranger saw you
saw your [ __ ] and said hey well they saw
this the space yeah and they're like
who's the biggest
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] hex over there
let's go let's go make them an offer you
can't refuse and you salted them yeah i
sold the majority of it [ __ ] yes
good [ __ ] bad things happened
what the [ __ ] was it were you trying to
do a sound board i was about to hit him
with the air horn but he said bad things
happen oh i thought that was the [ __ ]
sound thing marty what a terrible sound
but bad things happen that's not as
possible it wasn't it wasn't bad just a
little bit of uh missteps here and there
that led to my brand sort of looseness
luster right after you sold to them yeah
yeah a little bit yeah yeah uh there's
like intricacies to that we won't go
into just because whatever but the optic
fans that are watching this like they
know they know the story
the other thing that i like about og
things is that it'll warm you up and
it'll stay warm and it's not that's why
i got this [ __ ] right
uh anyway
sidetracked uh but yeah it's uh it
started to sort of go on like a downward
turn so at that moment i started to
you know figure out a way to buy it back
and for me to be back in control and you
know pointing in the in the right
direction so three years later i was
able to buy my brand back oh [ __ ] yeah
was it hopefully for less than what you
yeah yeah
wait what are you saying yesterday
i'm saying did you get a better deal
behind it back oh i don't know
oh okay so yes for me we'll just say it
at that
um no look at the end of the day you
know business people made the best
business decision at the time that they
needed to make sure
were you still running it even though
you sold it like no
no i tried i tried i tried to help i
tried so hard you weren't like the
president's though because so far
[Music]
and in the end
yo has there ever been a better [ __ ]
quote from a song to fit the story that
was incredible that's all the weed dude
do you think i'm gonna be this creative
perfect bro that was amazing uh seamless
yeah
anyway so yeah look it
at the end of the day as i said people
made the the best decisions for
themselves and their business at the
time that they needed to make it up but
but yeah it's a there's there's very
valuable like the top 20 or the top 10
most valuable orgs right it's go it goes
face at a billion as they just said it's
closer like uh i don't remember the
[ __ ] specific number so i got [ __ ]
brain freeze what does org mean
organization
okay yeah yeah or yeah um so phase
there's this team called tsm that was
valued at like 500 mil there was cloud
nine that i think was like a 300 mil
uh
my my boy nate shot and his company just
got like a 400 400 million dollar
evaluation evaluation based on just the
views uh
money baby value but what is the value
of the of the players of the
advertisement yeah i mean if you think
think about like this how the cowboys
are worth what five billion okay the
cowboys well what does that mean what's
what's what makes it worth that it's not
their revenues the revenues don't
justify them being worth five billion
now i get it it's how much somebody's
willing to pay for that [ __ ] team
so if jerry jones says that his team is
look people can estimate that the
cowboys are worth 5 billion but if you
ask jerry jones how much it would cost
for him to give up the cowboys he's
going to say
uh [ __ ] 40 bill 50 bill if i'm him
i'm thinking 100 bill
that's how much she's got i'm a i
already got bills what the [ __ ] you i
want to eat more bills for but there is
a certain level of bills that are that
that would make a billionaire be like
yeah those are more billions
right so it's it's worth what someone's
willing to pay for it
your show i'm going to i'm breaking a
cookie right then the show that you have
right now the most popular
cannabis
podcast in the industry
if somebody came in and said yo i want
to buy the rights to your [ __ ] okay
and then you're like all right well
can you just it was like how much is
your channel well my channel can't be
monetized makes no money
someone still wants to pay you for it
how how are they going to make their
money back well they'll figure it out
but that's how how it goes so valuations
are based on you know what they are to
give an example
optic is part of uh 12
of a 12
uh
person group
that decided to buy a franchise from
activision
to be one of 12. so we have uh texas so
we have optic texas
there is the there's two la teams la
thieves l.a gorillas
l.a gorillas just won the championship
this past weekend in minnesota now
how much did it cost to get into this
league 25
plus million dollars to buy the spot to
be in this league what so 12 12 people
12 people 12 groups right the crafts the
cronkies the the rams they own the la
gorillas that just won a championship in
call of duty yo this is a league [ __ ]
insane just brought my [ __ ] mind man
yeah i had no idea that there was more
than like five groups doing this
you said activision so they're the
explain like how they're the so
activision and activision owns call of
duty which means that they own the
metaverse of call of duty right the
world of call of duty
they own
nobody owns basketball if you foster
want to start the pot league right you
have your team i have my team
whatever we don't have to pay
basketball anything because basketball
belongs to the world that was the
perfect way to put it call of duty is
owned
by
an entity so i can't go and start my i
mean i could in theory but once you
start monetizing and become popular then
obviously then activation is like yo we
own this where's our cut
rightfully so they're the ones that are
investing in and doing all that [ __ ] and
sweat
what did you do before you started the
gaming what was your actual field of
work my last job was an account analyst
at aig
say because the way you're speaking and
breaking these shits down for me i feel
like you have done some presentations
before you applied that knowledge to
[ __ ] games 100 and then parlayed it
probably
before anybody i would imagine right
guys you guys are embarrassing me
i'm trying to wrap my head around but
please keep going
uh so i worked in the more uh in the uh
insurance industry
as an account analyst what i did was
made sure that
uh george lopez or where the [ __ ] had
their [ __ ] there
i
had the proper insurance so let's say he
has a house in in la
okay which he does
if it doesn't have earthquake insurance
or the proper whatever then he's exposed
and his three million dollar house
if he goes down in a [ __ ] earthquake
you're [ __ ] right it's not a shirt
so that's what i would do my biggest
account
was uh fakundo bakari
the great great great grandson of uh
bacardi empire oh god yeah this dude
you know much money mega wealthy too
much money there's levels to this yeah
you know
scary like yo no i bought the plane like
[ __ ]
all right let's go that's a different
level because i've
we've talked about it before but i'm
sure you have too have you ever been
around someone so rich you're uh
i can't chill with you [ __ ] how
much you just spend get away from me i
can't be there with you
that's my savings account yeah get away
from me yeah
it happened it happened two years ago
here in l.a yeah
and uh i was with a couple of friends
and i'm like i was at this one person's
house and i was like man it's been a
long time since i've felt poor
right this dude
oh it's a natchez house the the the
creator of minecraft ever heard of
minecraft yeah yeah so he sold to uh
microsoft for f 2.5 bill
and he be when he bought his house he
beat his bid was higher than jay-z and
uh and beyonce
78 bill 78 million or something like
that a house yeah a [ __ ] mega house
yeah and he just lets people chill there
and i'm like yo you're not afraid of
someone's going to steal your [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] are they going to steal they're
going to take how are they going to
where where are they going to take this
[ __ ]
three million dollar bike uh harley
davidson we're going to take that [ __ ]
okay where are you going to sell that
[ __ ]
yeah i get that
damn that's awesome so the guy that made
minecraft my little brother brought how
much money have i given to minecraft
never once pressed a button to play it i
mean a thousand dollars my little
brother oh
my brother yeah but no getting the
[ __ ] costumes for all the ween and
the swords for his room and buying this
and the the new oh [ __ ] my little
brother's a big gamer dude yeah big time
yeah yeah so growing up like minecraft
every five seconds that's all i heard
but it's my second favorite game of all
time i've never played it once when i
watch them play and go it's pixelated
i've been farming on minecraft since
[ __ ] uh since 2009.
i like minecraft because
it reverts you to the earlier stages of
humanity there's no technology no
but there is electricity somewhere
you just gotta harvest it i've never
played it i don't get it yeah it's a
survival game but it's a survival game i
mean it became so much more it is the
best game that has ever been created
ever period ever
easy it's my second it's my second
favorite but it's if we're looking at
facts and the coolness of it
it's like it's the best game that's ever
been created what
i just saw my little brother pixelated
when like he fell into a lava pit what
the [ __ ] am i watching yeah there wasn't
enough did you but did you know that if
you go if you if you collect bedrock i'm
sorry if you collect uh what's
dragonstone in minecraft
oh [ __ ] i'm so high i don't know i don't
know what it is uh it's it's a dark
let's pretend it's a uh
ma uh like [ __ ] lava that's turned
into a rock what's it called lava rock
magma
no lava rock man yeah
obsidian right it's called obsidian rock
if you collect 10 of them you can create
a portal that will take you to hell
in hell you go to a castle in which you
fight a fire monster that gives a
[ __ ] ablaze rod you bring this place
rod back to the reality you can make a
potion that can allow you to swim in
lava
see did you know that's how complex this
[ __ ] thing is somebody somebody
created
a computer
inside of minecraft
with minecraft's technology i don't even
get i don't know
exactly let's confuse the [ __ ] out of me
marty i was like me too what do you
think of like when franklin's in the
game playing a video game that type of
[ __ ] yeah there's a game within the game
oh yeah i don't know yeah it's called
yeah the service where you're spending
your money for your little brother i
think he's in a server might be in high
pixel or some [ __ ] like that
i don't know playing you know buying
[ __ ] skins and [ __ ] yes and then
going in there and [ __ ] playing like
mini games you can you can play a game
in minecraft where it's [ __ ] 10
levels of uh
of sand blocks that every time you step
on one you keep falling and falling and
falling
and there's like 24 people in there just
running around cubes trying to knock
each other out and that's the game
over and over again over and over and
over so you're saying that's the best
game ever created yeah it's just so good
so so good so simple yet so [ __ ]
complex like me
does your team play other games yeah
right now we play
we compete in uh call of duty obviously
as i mentioned uh halo valorant
uh and those are the ones right now
am i forgetting anything
no that's it you haven't heard of
valerie no i said never heard of that
yeah valerian it's like a it's a cartoon
counter-strike
never heard a counter-strike never okay
boom somebody who knows that is going to
laugh at the joke that i just made
it's everybody that follows us is a
gamer yeah everybody
shout out to everybody everybody because
i have a twitch like look it i just
don't have time to play i get hooked on
games
and if i start playing my oh uh i had to
do what i could do that [ __ ] tomorrow
and i'll be [ __ ] hooked
it's too fun i watched my cousin play
doom the other day games have gotten so
[ __ ] awesome lately doom i haven't i
mean i know what doom is i just haven't
played it in the new one yeah the night
i heard the newest holy [ __ ] it's
on another level and a elder ring or
something elden ring my little brothers
on that
dude games now are [ __ ] insane
they're fighting demons it's like a
masterpieces i'm just watching it's like
a movie dude it's incredible the call of
duty uh i play the story my my my uh
brother bought it for me because he
knows i'm like i'm not gonna buy it i'm
not gonna have time to play it
but now it's like what if i just do it
on twitch that's work to me now i can do
three hours every couple whatever and i
actually get to play games go all right
turn it off because if not i'll be up
till six in the morning playing the same
[ __ ] game bro
how i justified playing as much color as
i did just by making a living off of it
i'm like
am i i can't justify me spending this
much time if i'm not making money on it
and
pardon me little by little this became a
thing
since 2009
i've been out of the matrix since 2009.
[Music]
that's is it mainly youtube or do you
you is twitch in the mix yeah where does
it compare to youtube in your world so
so uh so
i was the ceo of optic for
as long as i you know since optic became
so but i was also a content creator
i just happened to be the oldest dude in
the room
right and understood what corporate
america was like so i thought that i you
know i i wasn't gonna compete without
top one percent of the top one percent
right so i'm like well where can i help
and that's where the business side of
the limited business side that i knew
happened like my first business was
optic
so that was another question when we
brought up gaming thing earlier i didn't
see it as gaming i didn't see it as i
saw it as more of like an entrepreneur
that
cause look it you're making money not
just off of and not even just making
money you're making a huge business off
of i'm assuming
merchandise after the fact
right oh yeah that's where a lot of this
comes from too right
so for a lot of people out there i know
this is like a game now this is i mean
this is like an actual career that
people see because my cousin that's all
he ever talked about like no i'll just
play games and he is [ __ ] amazing at
games
but he doesn't really like doing the uh
video part of it yeah but that i think
has to go hand in hand right now it does
yeah you can't just be like no man i
just want to play i'm gonna yeah i'm
gonna tell you why right now it does
right it's uh and i mean obviously like
you right successful podcast
uh how many other channels do you have
besides this one uh you have your vlog
channel right three two two or three
which ones can you monetize none oh one
one family friendly one the family
friendly one yeah right so like the the
the the ability to [ __ ] play this
game there's layers to it right because
you can get sponsorship money right for
you know people wanting to push their
glass people want to push their papers
whatever like that's a form of
advertisement that you get to take uh
partake on it
with
with your own merchandise with your own
product like you don't need to pay
advertise you you are the [ __ ]
advertisement you are what people are
paying to advertise so it's just as easy
for you to pay yourself by doing the
thing that you're already doing and
pushing your clothes
yeah pushing your treats episode one was
sponsored by push trees yep i've been
doing the push trees since 2013. so
that's all that paid my rent until i
started getting paid to do content yeah
night 2019 yeah that's the only reason i
was able to do it yeah
yeah so
one of the one of the things that i've
been able to do well is
get involved with uh
get involved in everything that i'm
passionate about and making business out
of them so i love bass fishing for
example
i started this streetwear brand
for bass fishermen called bashers in
2016. i figured if 10 of my audience who
also enjoys video games also enjoys
fishing they're gonna buy my [ __ ] cool
designs by me they know me so it's an
easy relationship
uh but through that i made friends with
uh
what are now the biggest fit you know
best fishing influencers in all of
youtube right because of you know me
knowing them them sort of listening to
my advice when it came to the strategy
behind youtube and how to grow
specifically on a team basis
uh so
you know that became a thing so now you
know i have ownership in in that brand
and it's like a massive mess massive
[ __ ] once in a lifetime brand and
fishing disrupter of the space you go to
any cabela's any dicks and like we're
the best soft baits company in the
united states oh it's a bait company
baits yeah like like worms and [ __ ] yeah
i got you what's it called uh googan
googin coogan
shout out to my boys so basically you
saw it as oh how are we going to
monetize what we're doing yeah oh we're
going to sell bait because it's
something you would sell like uh save me
like sell bonks
yeah your audience wants one yeah yeah
no
it's your business minded person that's
really what this is you're seeing it's
not you're taking advantage of people
it's like no no no you have to buy this
no no if you want it's us you it's made
by us you know we're not gonna yeah
[ __ ] yeah same [ __ ] in the video
because
why would any youtuber who has any level
of success try to push you on a
ten dollar like ten dollar is ten
dollars is not enough to ruin any trust
or relationship with that has that has
been feeding you for so long right
that's why you trust the influencers
that's why you you that's why
advertisers pay influencers what they
pay
and credibility yeah because of the
credibility because they're not going to
just talk [ __ ] because then they're
going to be well i just betrayed my
people
you know what i mean so that's why
that's why we're valuable because we
have that level of access that they
don't and sometimes you know people [ __ ]
up right like this is this is we're
humans so i'm not saying the [ __ ] up
right you're saying papa's perfect no
okay uh but uh there there have been
influencers that have like promoted the
wrong thing of course and it was like
like you would have made the same
[ __ ] mistake these are young people
who have never had a sense of business
and and their manager or they thought it
was a good idea it wasn't
you know i was gonna say sue them but no
don't [ __ ] sue them
though because
i've seen some people that i know i'm
like whoa you're advertising that oh no
i don't do that one yeah it's not it
just doesn't fit you yeah but you tell
them of course good that's a good friend
whitener bro you're a [ __ ] rapper
mm-hmm why are you doing teeth whitening
ads right now your credibility is not
looking good right now look like
yourself you have good teeth
no they were grills and [ __ ] oh i'm just
saying like enchant like
doesn't matter it'd be like me
advertising some [ __ ] yeah i don't
know how about how about how about
nicotine some [ __ ]
down thank you like we turn we
if me and mark if i accepted everything
i'd do 100 videos a month you know i'm
saying there's only certain things that
i can pick and choose and go no yeah i
know my audience will like that i really
hope this is worth it yeah that's the
only time i'll do [ __ ] yeah that's we
pick and shoot we turn down
[ __ ] every day yeah yeah it
doesn't work oh yeah the nicotine comes
[ __ ] we
go turn down this [ __ ] we turned it
down just based off the fact of we don't
support cigarettes and [ __ ] yeah
lo and behold i go and put on youtube
they're advertising the [ __ ] company
on our [ __ ] money on our ads i'm like
oh man you guys got us anyway yeah you
passed yeah yeah but you got a cut of
that your channel should oh this channel
is monetized yeah yeah this channel is
my main one my main ones and that's the
[ __ ] bummer
it was monetized for the first like year
and a half but
it would always say like four cents
and then it'd be a gray bar across to
like it could be like opaque is what you
call it transparent yeah yeah yeah and
then one time youtube gave me like six
hundred dollars and i went oh my god you
paid me
but i see the numbers they still run ads
they don't pay me anything and then last
year they gave me a message saying
you're not i'll ever mind uh eligible
for monetization
erase basically take your videos down
for reevaluation or whatever
but they owe me like over almost two
points like eight million dollars man
because i've gotten a lot of [ __ ]
views on my channel yeah my
views versus ads so that's different no
no i'm talking about they were all
monetized but i never got no money it
was a gray bar across he remembers
there's a gray bar across my [ __ ]
ads are coming in i go on social blade
my t the double jewel is making this
much money like what the where i never
got that [ __ ] and then one day it had
like five bands in it and i went oh my
[ __ ] god and then it disappeared the
next day
they're running ass they're running ads
you should you should you should
i mean they've deleted me before too
yeah legal recourse man i know but look
i'm not saying hey youtube i'm not i'm
not saying
especially nowadays like you can verify
whether or not there were ads running
against it the whole time yeah but so
that's where this is for me it's like i
just want a place i can post [ __ ] the
money like i'll let him keep the money
because i it's more valuable to me to be
able to talk to everybody make content
is more valuable because in the long run
i'll make more money than that
so i don't want them to be like [ __ ] you
you want your money now erase this
channel forever oh guys this is a
community here yeah yeah that's what
pissed me off the most dude
so have you tried have you reached out
to anyone on youtube
no okay all right yeah
oh my god yo i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
honest with you earlier
while we were [ __ ] i heard something
and i'm like no
it's the voices dude
but now i know you're pushing [ __ ]
that's why i said no i keep monkeys
sometimes marty put some funny ass
noises yeah yeah that's what i meant
good timing all right good timing i
can't believe you haven't been putting
the [ __ ] the laughter in the
background every single time i've said a
joke
i'm a real [ __ ] laughter yeah he's
the audience yeah
so you're saying i can talk to somebody
youtube i got you i'm gonna put you in
contact with someone to at least
appreciate it start start the
conversation about like what's going
wrong
yeah man because sometimes it's like
bro i didn't do nothing wrong it's not
even it's not even the money yeah it's i
get age-restricted and shadow bands so
heavy i get yeah i understand age
restrictions and a thousand people a day
like yo i'm unfail i unsubscribed again
no
hundreds hundreds of people
daily like i'm still unsubscribed on my
my
legal channel like the one that i don't
smoke or nothing i have like two twenty
thousand on there but i don't use it you
know what i'm saying order one the [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
i got my my
my friend joseph was over there and i'm
like yo let me get another slushie he's
like there's no more
[ __ ] okay so [ __ ] me
order all of me
uh
yeah people every day like you know i'm
unsubscribed again on this channel too
like it keeps unsubscribing me
and people like unliking like i liked
the video when it started and now it's
not liked again
so it's like is it like a little [ __ ]
you to me i'm so explicit because i'm
not a channel like i don't know i'm
gonna tell you something it's not they
don't they [ __ ] it's automated
there's no there's no human
back there that has a grudge against you
or your channel but thing is i've been
deleted 25 times yes but that's snapchat
yeah yeah okay those are
those are those are different
google and the amount of channels that
exist on its platform has to be
automated
i feel that one uh one of my best
friends
was the head of gaming of of google up
until
like last month when he moved to polygon
studios
so i'm plugged in you know what i mean
you need to get through the door i got
you
dude appreciate i just honestly
everybody that's just watching this in
the chat right now went for real because
they know
i get [ __ ] played on the internet
yeah and you've never reached out to
anyone trying to i went to instagram
once and they told me get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah i don't know about
instagram yeah instagram is the only
place where i i think i have a plug i
don't even i mean it's not even certain
it's it's i think i think
i think i can got you but yeah for
youtube like twitter youtube shadowman
hard uh it's it's
it's weird it's weird they deleted me
for a month
didn't respond to anything they were
just like on some giving us the run
around like oh there must be a mistake
here
i was at 995. on youtube yeah get the
[ __ ] nine nine five i don't know i don't
know there might be a person that that
sounds like we were emailing back and
forth with a live person and then and
then they told us [ __ ] off for a month
marty pulled the race card for me eight
minutes later my channel's back
because it was for real i'm like yo why
mm-hmm what did i do differently
[ __ ] yeah there's only one if
there's an equation
you know i'm like the only thing that's
that's left to be like i didn't want to
go there yeah exactly like it took me
eight years to say it but
is it this yeah [ __ ] man i don't even
speak spanish at this part yeah you're
like yo he's cool man no responses
yeah exactly and then no response no
emails channel was just on
getting these chairs i was driving to
pick up these chairs and my [ __ ]
channel was back what the [ __ ] it has to
be automated yeah and i was gaining like
maybe three or four thousand subscribers
a day [ __ ] now i'm at like
400 200 a day and it's like it's like
people like i haven't seen you post in
months yeah oh dude i post every
thursday [ __ ] and every video had about
[ __ ] 30 hours going to it
at least because of my main channel like
it's like we're at 1.3 right it took a
year to hit 300 300 000 more mm-hmm and
before that it'd be like 80 a month
like whoa all right what are you doing
[ __ ] but it's okay
i just don't know what the problem is
man like i don't know what it is well
we'll we'll try to figure it out well i
won't but i'll you know i'm gonna pass
that up to
a friend in there i have uh yeah it's
it's more than likely just [ __ ] some
something that you got dinked for super
early on that no longer applies but the
algorithm still recognizes it look ai
man they don't give a [ __ ]
that's crazy now what about when wilford
weed goes federally legal
in your opinion like um i'm like when
that happens the doors are gonna [ __ ]
when youtube like when we becomes a
category on youtube officially
[ __ ] yeah but even then you gotta
because look you think taco bell doesn't
wanna [ __ ] advertise potheads
i a hundred percent i don't have
here's here's
here's why have you responsible
well
the lady that used to do the marketing
yeah she's a [ __ ] she was a weak
company and she told me like all we do
is think about potheads and that's why
we have fourth meal yeah and then she
grabbed my [ __ ] dick drunk at a party
and then i walked away
and then i that's the story so ladies
and gentlemen your [ __ ] fault
yeah she was faded
damn that's why i know taco bell i
always [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh hey man her
boyfriend was eight feet away oh [ __ ]
get away from me i felt so disgusting um
yeah it's the the the thing that's gonna
finally open it up for and i'm talking
about just everyone on the internet
right is the advertisers
it's not it's not the platforms it's not
you know it's not [ __ ] youtube it's
not twitch it's not google it's not
amazon it makes me feel better yeah no
it's not it's not it's not the platforms
in which we operate it's the it's the
i'm gonna tell you what it is
there's this [ __ ] old-ass dude
head of uh you know vp of marketing for
pepsi okay the vp of marketing for pepsi
and he is really good friends with some
other old gray-haired [ __ ]
across the street that runs the biggest
ad agency ever okay and at the end of
every year he sends him a gift and he
sends them a gift says hey thank you for
spending money on tv and on [ __ ]
newspapers and [ __ ] billboards and
[ __ ]
beneath all these old dudes there's
dark handsome ass [ __ ]
you know
women that are just ready to [ __ ]
make some cash you know what i mean
killers
advertisement killers that are just
ready to be like why the [ __ ]
are we spending the majority of our
advertising dollars
still in the world instead of the
you know the the internet
like that's where the money needs to go
but they're like hey i've always bought
you know the the sunday paper and this
is my boy from the paper
who sent me some periwinkle at the end
of the [ __ ]
you know whatever
pappy van winkle's saying what i'm
trying to say at the end of the year and
you know say hi to marsha and say hi to
whoever right once those dudes retire
and go the [ __ ] away and maybe it might
take like i don't know that one and the
one right below him before they get to
the young people that truly understand
the where this thing's going where the
true eyeballs are that's when all of
this the the flawed gates are just going
to boom right so the generation has to
die off yeah basically yeah yeah i mean
not die off retire off yeah
hypothetically yeah and what they choose
to do
afterwards yeah yeah what they choose to
do they want to die
like it's a choice
you know it's like well
when they choose to whatever so so yeah
it's not it's not the platforms in which
we operate we're just super early
everything that we're building now
we're gonna we're gonna see a little bit
of it
but the majority of the
mechanics of all of the money that's
gonna be coming into the internet
you know it's 10 years 15 years down the
line yeah after we i mean we you're
you're still young we're still going to
be around for that we're going to take
it but we're just going to have to wait
we have to build and wait that's the
worst
there's a [ __ ] mega youtuber that is
13 years old doesn't have a youtube
channel yet but it's going to be that
because everybody before him has to
allow to teach how you spend proper
money
on the internet you know what i mean
totally it's like sort of tell my
players now right like uh the
call it 350 a year you get paid as a
professional call of duty player minimum
not a minimum the minimum is uh 50 000.
sorry
yeah
yeah some people are making like 350 a
year wow yeah like to play
yeah yeah
right like those those people these
these players are all laying down the
groundwork for the 3.5 million dollar
contract yeah it's just like an old
football player jim brown and that's the
reason why [ __ ] marshawn lynch
can get 100 mil mm-hmm i get it yeah
yeah it's the same in podcasting like
you always say like the spotify with
rogan and then the pat mcafee deal with
fanduel and now that's all setting
precedence for
it to be normal yeah
yeah yeah so it's it's uh
the thing about
everything that we're doing now like
we're just replicating for old media
that has that but but we're doing
ourselves a disservice if we follow the
book and the blueprint we have to
plug our own [ __ ] into it because for us
to do the same thing that they did
it's not going to work with this thing
you know so we have to sort of invent on
top of what they've already invented
yeah innovate innovate let's get let's
go you guys are getting some life
lessons here all right these are [ __ ]
great lessons to soak and absorb [ __ ]
also no it's not don't listen to
i'm not advising anyone i i would i
would take that as advice from me
i'll [ __ ] second that because
that's pretty much the show is we preach
a lot of
get out of the matrix well not even so
much that if that's what you like that's
what you like just if you're not
running the [ __ ] if you're not
you know what if you're not happy doing
it why are you doing it you know what
i'm saying there's always another day
you can wait here tomorrow
that's most people's fear of change and
or failure like dude i failed a bunch of
times too eat a dick that was a while
back
you know what i'm saying you have to
throw the ball like 80 times before
you're like yo that's a pretty good
[ __ ] spiral for the first time bro i
went i went what and i'm not broke
necessarily but i lost
like my livelihood when i was [ __ ] at
27 years 27 28 years old and then 2009
happens the internet allows me to make
money on [ __ ] that i was already doing
and then everything [ __ ] changed
right and so if you're younger than 27
you can get like it's never too late to
get
out of it you know what i mean any
[ __ ] age too though yeah especially
bro the internet has a lot more the
internet has allowed you to be able it's
like the key for you to get out of the
matrix there are channels out there bro
no [ __ ] and i watch these
now
there's i watch these dudes set up
cameras and then set up their camping
equipment they don't talk they don't
teach they don't say anything and they
just set it up for like an hour straight
just and they cook their [ __ ] meals
and i'm just [ __ ] watching they're
not even talking they're just recording
themselves there are channels out there
that are re that are putting a a
30-minute loop sound of uh fire
crackling
and then putting that video out for 10
hours yep 100 million views yeah because
some people i mean it's
the rain people i want to know what kind
of people that do the rain i thought
about this the other day how much are
they making there's like 200 300 million
views on summer videos yeah it's [ __ ]
insane
what's insane is that they did that
14 times
sign of rain rain in cambodia rain in
the forest rain at the beach
waves crashing
rain at the rain at the strip club
[Music]
just people talking that'd be kind of
cafe sounds street signs
on twitch there's some people that just
stream cctv or live stream tv
like uh let's go to russia
click a city in russia you just see a
cafe
camera yeah click somewhere else you're
at a basketball game outside yeah it's
fun twitch people watch other people
play video games all day
all day that's every day yeah that's
that's where it's at minecraft has
channels that are literally like uh
building a snowy cabin in the woods
and they're not talking they're just
playing minecraft building a snowy cabin
in the [ __ ] woods for [ __ ] three
hours three hundred thousand views
fourteen ad spread in between
oh [ __ ] it man that's that's like
a 27 cpm by that by that point
so how much say uh
again is it gamers because i know music
is paid differently on youtube our
gamers play different paid differently
than just regular people vlogging and
[ __ ] which is all basically the same
music yeah same thing
those are the guys are making money how
much money do you get per million
uh
back in the day it used to be a
guarantee two dollars and fifty cents
wait back in the day two dollars and
fifty cents per million views yeah no uh
per thousand views so twenty five bucks
okay
nowadays it varies because there's
mid-rolls
which are the the ads that you put in
the middle as you know so your first uh
pre-roll the pre-roll the the one that
plays below and there can be two of
those those can each be
five bucks each right so that's a 10 cpm
right minus
whatever youtube takes and all that [ __ ]
right and whatever your your mcn takes
unless you're direct to that and then in
the middle there might be like a 50 cent
ad that they a little banner that pops
up some quick and then another one and
another one uh ten minutes later so one
dollar cpm so i didn't know that they
had prices on them
in theory oh yeah yeah
that's how my my brain interprets
whatever it is that it's it's something
it's like that it's it's that
just the exact of it it's not it's just
theorizing [ __ ] so it varies but on the
low end you're making about five bands
even if you just put like one or two ads
on a million dollar a million view video
oh on a million view video 100 percent
yeah but but but see you're you're
you're not looking at it holistically
right because one video let's say you're
a podcast let's say what pocket you put
our pockets that's 25 minutes long it's
something quick
right you get in in that podcast you
advertise uh raw paper i know you just
have to do it here right
they'll give you
i don't know i'm theorizing right
they'll give you i don't know 15 grand
for for the spot
most popular [ __ ] it's not just the
views is the status that you're
podcasting thank you yeah you need to be
our [ __ ] pitch man yeah right so
don't get me started this comes natural
to me
uh so
all right so it's not it's not about how
much
youtube pays you is how much money you
make on that one single piece of content
so you have a 20 minute video you'll
make and i'm talking [ __ ] here you
make a thousand dollars on that video at
the end of the month it's a thousand
dollars that youtube's gonna pay you for
that one video well on top of that there
was like three really funny clips
that you also uploaded right you know
uploaded the shorts
shorts is you know whatever like nothing
but in that shorts you're
selling a one exclusive piece of t-shirt
merch and then that's [ __ ] money so
you got merch you got your adsense on
top of that you got raw paying you for
that so you're making money on the ads
that youtube's running
on the [ __ ] money that this dude paid
to [ __ ] advertise that one little
spot in the middle of your thing is like
yo guys for real that no [ __ ] ross
is where it's at right boom right you
get paid for that to say that and then
on top of that you're like well this
episode was brought to you by expressvpn
right or it actually [ __ ] is okay it
is
cool
all right well let's let's go let's you
want to tell them about expressvpn
what a better way to go into this ad
read the most organic thing you ever saw
so introduced to the dope as usual
podcast this is one of our newest
sponsors this is expressvpn if you
didn't know my dobasiola channel is
banned in russia and philippines if your
ip address is in any of those countries
you cannot watch any dopaziola video for
the past
four or five years so when expressvpn
approached us i thought perfect let me
break it down as easy as possible for me
all right for people like me that aren't
great with computers here we go when you
look something up whoever provides your
internet can see every single thing
you're doing because they own that part
they can see everything so no matter
what you think no matter how many times
you clear your data how many times you
clear your cookies all that stuff it
still shows up with expressvpn once it's
enabled it goes through their server and
comes back out somewhere else so it it
can't be tracked and it doesn't show
exactly what you're looking at so
basically like if you're in russia or
philippines and you want to watch a
dopazilla video you click and enable
expressvpn and it shoots you to another
place where it is okay to watch that and
now you're watching dopagiola channel
for all of our fans out there expressvpn
and our podcast have teamed up to give
you guys this offer if you go to
expressvpn.com forward slash yola when
you get the year subscription your first
three months are automatically free just
because you watch this episode if this
interests you at all guys remember
expressvpn.com forward slash yolo that's
three months free out of the first
all right i'm on a different year right
now
channel and shirt all right so
plus right so you so some dude that you
know said yo i'm gonna give you like 15
grand for you to talk about this new
[ __ ] raw paper rolls itself
breaks your weight up and [ __ ] all right
all right so boom you advertise that you
got your 15 there but then expressvpn is
giving you whatever they're giving you
right so there's another one and then
youtube's running the ads but that's
another one but then you split that [ __ ]
up into three different videos for three
different little things and then one of
them got sent to twitter uh you're
probably not monetized on twitter right
because you can get [ __ ] paid you
know well no it's right now it's no
right now they're they're testing out
the the things the the
you know it's a big platform etc so
they've been testing for a while now
yeah if you see ads
someone's getting paid
yeah if you see ads like someone's
getting paid right so this one video
that you created created an infinite
amount of opportunities
right for you to make money for the rest
of life
for the rest of your life right because
what if you become a [ __ ]
i don't know you're you're 30 million
subscribers everybody that smokes weed
in the world is now subscribed to you 10
years down the line
well you guys want to see a [ __ ] clip
from [ __ ]
2015 you remonetize that and it makes
more money than it's ever made before so
you know what i'm saying like i get what
you're saying yeah i understand that i
love that you broke that down because i
hope [ __ ] retain that yeah
that's the opportunity you have when you
do [ __ ] yourself
so a thousand dollars essentially is
what i got for the youtube money yeah
that's what i was just assuming like
like because the rest of it
that's the whole point of what we do
like everything else has to it has to
when you don't get paid for certain
things yeah but to say for everyone out
there that was an example
we do not get paid to bring guests on
we didn't charge josh to come on the
show sorry just in case you're like oh
no no no no i know but i shouldn't have
said raw yeah no no but you just use it
as an example yeah great example no but
i do understand having to clear up like
logical things that should there are a
couple of 15 you know slower
[ __ ] out there that need that
additional you know pause and be like
hey hold on all right
every time
just declare you look i know you don't
mean your harm
but you can't die we know you don't
understand man it's cool you're cool
you're cool yeah but but let me [ __ ]
get better just
give it one more
challenge yourself one more time before
you open your [ __ ] mouth yeah yeah
one thing i always preach to people is
like yo think about what you're going to
say first yeah in your head
say it out bro the the best the best
thing that anybody in the world can do
that does what we do is to talk to them
directly the way that you would talk to
any of your friends exactly right no one
no no one here is better than anyone we
you just happened he just happened to do
a video
that popped personality one of a kind
you know that sort of thing but we're
all equals therefore i'm not gonna talk
to you yeah this ain't a fan
[ __ ] personality relationship no this
is uh homies
you watch us i don't know you yet well
maybe you will one day
that's the first thing i recognized
about him versus all the kids
[ __ ] they they a lot of entertainers
think of themselves
of course thomas was just like 100
percent community 100 yeah that's why
it's so strong 100
yo whether it's like we're on here the
camera's off or in the store like it's
the same [ __ ] thing yeah it's always
going to be the same and i'm just as
stoked as [ __ ] to be like you i watch
your [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah anytime yeah
yes because that's the way you stay
i mean
if you're that way anyway i think that
you're just winning anyway like i want
to be your friend if that's how you are
everywhere 100 yeah it'd be tiring
otherwise man you don't mean like if i
had to
be nice turn it on you're gonna be like
oh god i have to be nice i have to
pretend to be nice
like no i'm not nice but i'm not mean
neither i'm gonna talk to you the same
way i talk to my players who are my
teammates and friends
nobody at my or on my organization has
never talked to me like a [ __ ] equal
you know what i mean i i this boss [ __ ]
like i don't do that like i'm gonna talk
to you as equals we're both here to do a
job i just happen to be getting older
yeah that's it only difference yeah of
course that's it [ __ ] yeah but my social
media guy always sends me every time i
post food
my [ __ ] calls me a fat ass every single
time my social media guys you know what
i mean yeah like that's the relationship
that i have with my people because i was
yeah but you know like
you know that's that's the that's that's
the thing and i and i treat everybody
the same way to do
me
to do you bro like think about how much
harder it'd be if you have to fake this
oh i think about that i said it the
other day could you imagine going to
sleep going okay was that good on
everyone oh no i acted oh [ __ ] could you
could you imagine that stress people
stress in your life having i've met
those people yeah and i always think i
feel bad for you i do
because i couldn't imagine being that
stressed out inside
oh man
the internet has allowed for superstars
to be superstars without the [ __ ] you
know the charades
which is good it's a great equalizer man
exactly
you know what i mean like i would have
been a [ __ ]
ray you know corporate rat race
[ __ ] for the rest of my life if
it wouldn't have been for the internet
i love that i would just sold packs for
the rest of my life it wasn't for the
internet why did you start smoking weed
uh 1997 uh graduation day
yeah yeah middle of the football field
steamroller
whoa hold on hold on middle of the
football field means that oh no no no no
no no no no no no in illinois no no my
parents would have been there that's why
no no no no i was like
sorry yeah let me
i see it like vividly obviously and i
just assume everybody sees it too it was
it was it was night it was close to like
1am it was after after
no yeah it was after the graduation
party at someone's house
and you had been avoiding weed because i
was like that's
corporate america doesn't like that and
if you get so i i was i was kind of well
i painted trains by night right so i
would i have a bank job
i worked in the banks and then in the
mortgage industry and then find uh
insurance at the end um but like i would
i would go if i would have caught pain
if i would have been caught painting
trains i would have caught a felony or
something and that would have been a
smudge on my record and in corporate
america they don't like that [ __ ] so i
was running that risk so putting weed on
top of that like that's a drug you know
what i mean so
i mean you know i feel you
no [ __ ] i love that yeah that that's the
day you're like [ __ ] it so once you
start smoking sorry go ahead that's just
what i was going to say regularly
after that or yeah i put no i
i never had my own weed
oh totally did you get the party yeah
i'll hit that yeah i'll get you yeah and
it wasn't because like i was trying to
be [ __ ] shady or not by my own way it
just wasn't it just wasn't like like i
didn't need it and if it was there like
yeah but like immediately
uh as i as you know as i mentioned i
used to draw a lot so immediately my
brain was like a little bit better more
creative like i didn't know that that
was a possibility yeah and
like immediately i just i just liked it
and i and i didn't want to like it
because
it's evil you know what i mean it's
your parents are real mexican you're
gonna sound like my grandma and grandpa
right now yeah whoo
even though my mom
and my dad well my dad specifically was
a [ __ ] mega mega death [ __ ] queen
[ __ ] uh like [ __ ] had long hair
hippie [ __ ] you know what i mean
like suave uh-huh you know something i
know you smoked at some point i've seen
your eyes
and he says i only smoked once and it
didn't because it made me sleepy i'm
like no shot weed made you sleepy back
then or maybe
hell no
there's no way what did you feel trash i
say that i say that but shy tom brown
that i smoked growing up still got me
high
a blunt still got me high
i think is it is it as high as i get
nowadays i don't know i don't think so
different the weed now is just on
another level
there's some oh geez i smoke that i go
not because it's harsh just like are you
[ __ ] kidding me so good it's just so
funny why
yeah uh but as a kid i think back in
being a kid yeah well so hold on sorry
you started smoking consistently wind uh
[ __ ] man consistently where you're like
i have wheat in my own
about four years ago oh wow it took you
a long time well yeah i mean
it was it was ingrained in me
that it was bad and
society had put me in a position to
where i had to choose between living the
life that i wanted to live
and i had to have the jobs that i had to
have
so i had to you know make a choice i get
it
or be a [ __ ] criminal basically every
time you re-up and [ __ ] like it's so
[ __ ] right so [ __ ] up i can't smoke
weed in my house man i can't smoke weed
in my house i have to wait because
you're in texas yeah and i'm like and
think about the risk you don't even
think about my risk right
i'm [ __ ] i mean i don't know if i'd be
[ __ ] because i i think i can afford a
good enough lawyer notice luckily okay
yeah right but like at the same time
like you know i'm i'm i'm
a head of a business and i am an advisor
and a bunch of others
and you know me being in the news for
smoking weed wouldn't mean a [ __ ] to the
fans nothing right it would mean to my
industry but there are going to be like
a couple of people are going to be
you know
luckily for me i've gotten to a place
where whatever i do like
i'm not gonna get into trouble with
anyone i just can't like if if
i'm not a bad person so i can't get
canceled right like i'm never gonna do
something that's cancelable right so
if someone's gonna have a problem with
me and even if they shun me from the
[ __ ] internet it's too late you know
what i mean
don't send me you don't send me into
retirement to go have a fight a life of
solitude wait time out i don't have to
talk to anyone uh
my friends are still got my friends
[ __ ] all this yep
the the people that know me on the
internet we're still gonna be cool do i
feel like he this is some [ __ ] we've
said but almost verbatim before yeah but
we don't do [ __ ] that's canceled
everything is exciting [ __ ] yeah give a
give my friends at my home i don't give
a [ __ ] like you're not gonna bug me good
i'm canceled who cares yeah cause you
can't cancel somebody and you gotta make
some you have to make some [ __ ] up about
me yeah that's how i feel yeah i'm like
i'm not i'm i'm not a bad person i'm
never i'm i'm not gonna hate on a on
anyone just because of something that
they didn't choose to be
you know what i mean i'm not gonna i
mean and i'm mexican i can't be racist
you know what i mean
because they don't speak spanish i like
all mexicans
i like all mexicans yeah yeah
i went to nice girl though and they were
like what
like three years ago yeah like you know
expanded like they were racist towards
you weren't they oh big time
that ella you know that sound hmm
look at that
sound of disappointment
he brought my kids took it away
i i got he walks in with my juice and
i'm like yeah and then he moves away
uh this one
um all right so speaking of weed yeah
pine park pine park and this is how i
was became of like
i'm chilling with eric let me say this
better i'm chilling with eric
and he's talking about the gaming and
like i don't know about that like you've
never seen
the [ __ ] gaming because i've i've
seen people still quick scope oh my god
i [ __ ] shot i didn't know they're
making music videos essentially of the
baller ass [ __ ] online i didn't know
that they showed me
he showed me uh
he showed me you
like so
you just own a game i'm like that's a
thing and then they explained everything
to me so
that's when i looked you up i'm like oh
okay what the [ __ ] are we company yeah
so pine park
how did this start since you're in texas
you have to come back here and yeah
curate everything so you're back and
[ __ ] forth yeah which i was already
doing that anyway right like a lot of my
friends are here uh
it's good to make youtube videos and you
know over here because of the
accessibility to other creators that are
you know big or big enough to to do that
although texas has like a bun like a
good com like uh preston places there
like massive people are there dude
perfect it's right across the street for
i know i actually know who they are
i actually so you like what do you watch
on youtube
i watch horrible things
they took fights off youtube and it
really upset me bum fights and [ __ ] i
used to just watch [ __ ] world star
vine compilations yeah fights every
friday yeah [ __ ] yeah i just watch
comedians doing [ __ ]
i don't watch youtubers or channels yeah
it's random [ __ ] i click oh
norm mcdonald
okay
and i'll watch like oh guys normally
that old lady wrestling piece yes
i was just random [ __ ] did that right is
that the one that yeah norm yeah he
passed away um that was good because i
was gonna make a joke
if you would have said like any other
comedian i would have been like ah you
know kevin hart the youtuber
right because he's on youtube a lot it's
a big part of his business
really yeah
youtube is a part of every if you're if
you're an entertainer
you got to be
so [ __ ] brat pit rich right or that
sort of a like top a
celebrity for the last 20 years
consistently before the internet
basically yeah to not want to have like
youtube or give your fans access to you
on a daily basis
i mean the the that that's the beauty
again of what we get to do we get to be
friends with [ __ ] everyone and you
always [ __ ] up is that they could have
also been friends with [ __ ] everyone
too that the [ __ ]
yeah i just think some i think some
people uh have that entitlement i think
they just think they're too [ __ ]
famous they're cool but i see that a lot
i'm gonna tell you something i have my
own rules though okay that's a popular
person on the internet i have my rules
if you see me
at a restaurant and i'm standing up
waiting hell yeah let's take a picture
100
if there's a fork in my hand
with meat on it do not [ __ ] come near
me
i'm eating this might this is me time
i don't let i don't let anyone come my
dogs no one comes near me when i'm
eating it goes back to blocking the
flame and [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah it's his first day of high school
he saw that fight and someone stole his
lunch like oh [ __ ]
never quite but only because i don't
know how speaking of the childhood i
would have talked my way out of it
out of my dude
why are we
this is a simulation imagine 1994 it's a
simulation what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] the
simulation you signed up for this [ __ ]
bro you don't understand
yeah
there's there's uh there's like no
special effects back then uh-huh you
know i i talk about the 90s as if they
were like the black and white pictures
yeah that's where i feel like
though that's where i've gotten to the
point yeah but it feels like you do
shit's so crazy now everybody has a
[ __ ] computer in their hand and it's
so insane
how do you go to school and not get
straight [ __ ] that's right it's gonna
be tough
how do you not have straight a's just
i'm gonna [ __ ]
how do you not make a tape put in your
[ __ ] earpod and go hey answer a
i just realized how snashy i am sorry um
i'm just spilling ashes oh you're good
you're good but that's what we do here
that's
you should see me
there's weed that's from earlier what
the [ __ ] that's when i rolled the choice
um so sorry pine park yeah
what is i mean
if you're coming back to california
you're curating it i saw you said
yesterday you were doing your harvest
yeah that was eric was with me yes that
was uh
light depth yeah that one where is that
up north uh no it was uh yeah it's in
san jose area oh yes santa cruz that's
what it looks like yeah so
you know the the the beauty of
everything that i'm doing is that i get
to
learn everything for the first time you
know what i mean because everybody's so
spoiled over here right you can go and
if you want
og you can go get it yeah in in texas or
in illinois when i was living in
illinois you got what the [ __ ] you got
right so so developing a palette to
identify
strains
developing a the ability to sense
yourself in a state or in a mood
while being high and then trying to
remember that as a sober person like
it's difficult right so it takes
training so i get to do all that
a lot of it on camera which means that
other people who are also cannabis
enthusiasts that don't have the access
that californians or other legal states
have get to sort of vicariously live and
learn through what i'm learning
i like it yes which is why like the
first season of pine park we first
season yeah so it's like every you know
obviously there's there's strains that
come out in different seasons oh okay
okay you're calling it like that oh like
a youtube season i was like no wait you
guys it hasn't been long what it is
yeah well we're on season uh three four
oh three is three season three [ __ ] i
don't know that's that's [ __ ] that's
how we do the show we do season one
season two yeah uh that's what that's
there's like this is a show right like
uh this is a a piece of art right
because the growers you know anybody can
grow it's not just an artist
i love that yeah they call it seasons
yeah season one yeah so season one yeah
i love it season one we had we had chem
driver and chem reserve being grown at
the same time and my thought behind it
was
if people can get a chance to try two
cousin plants
they'll be able to like sort of tell the
difference in the taste and the potency
and
that
i don't know if it really you know i
don't even know if i can you know
identify the difference right now you
will be able to yeah at one point yeah
so i was like all right so this is like
as i'm learning like how would i like to
learn and be able to tell the difference
between these things i'm like well let
me try side by side right so i'll buy an
eighth of this underneath of that
you know so you know they get
once once you start training yourself to
understand the difference at that level
then you'll be you're gonna be able to
tell the super difference between
uh that super cheese that you have in
there and what you have here right
because there are different you know
smells different tastes 100
yeah
that's cool man because if you're
like you're saying they're living with
you like say they're like you know i'm i
like we too i [ __ ] love optic gaming
i love call of duty oh [ __ ] i can now go
smoke what you're smoking and learn what
you're learning at the same time yeah so
i'm our lead geneticist or genetics guy
who has a [ __ ] incredible library of
like super old
you know some you know so the guy's
going to be developing our own genetics
proprietary genetics he watched my
videos
when he was a kid when he was like a 13
year old dude he's been watching optic
for over a decade and now he and i get
to work together
on this thing erican you know you know
part owner of of pine park
also used to watch my videos as he was
growing up crazy right so the way that i
see it is like all of the people like
all the people that support you that
have been supporting you for so long and
then you're you're you're for one day
like i want to start a window installing
company i don't know where to begin some
dude is like hey my dad [ __ ] owns one
why don't we you know whatever then
you're like you'd rather work with him
than anybody else because they've been
supporting you just your turn to sort of
i guess we make most of our connections
yeah it's through people we've got
through being advanced yeah so for me
like i can go into any state and license
my [ __ ] and have people there because
you know i'm a global personality in the
gaming industry specifically in call of
duty and people have been watching me
for a long time so if i go to illinois
i'm going to have a crowd if i go
wherever i go i'm going to have a crowd
so
the other weird thing about this whole
thing is like as i was sitting in our in
our facility in the pine park
headquarters i'm calling them
laboratories from now on
we're building technologies
for you know people to take in
technologies anyway
we're as i'm sitting there i'm like you
know what's [ __ ] up is that people
that watch me
are going to be smoking one of these
[ __ ] plants that i've been 100
and at some point
a lot of members of the green wall which
is what we call you know our community
that we're all going to be smoking the
same thing
at the same time
from the same room
like they may have been like right those
plants may have been together they may
have been in the same [ __ ] plant so i
might i might block no i was like no
what you said when i dropped a strain
like two years ago we were supposed to
make a company didn't work the [ __ ] out
long story
i did a review i mean i did the vlog and
i was we were getting everything down
like guys there's only small batches you
might smoke this this one this very one
right here and it blew my mind thinking
yeah
oh my god that's [ __ ] insane it's
it's
it's so crazy because like until last
month we packed every i packed every
order of everything we always did
everything
and everybody just thought isn't that
crazy knowing that you [ __ ] packed
this [ __ ] and put the sticker and wrote
this little i'm like yeah
it is kind of [ __ ] awesome because
it's it's it's a little more personal i
think yeah you know it is and they think
it's crazy because they're getting it
from you how crazy you think it is for
us that we're like we're sending this
one to two i can't believe all you have
yeah [ __ ] with me like that that's how
that's we preached that on the show like
wow
isn't that like we were at a concert
like
there's this many people like our
premieres
yeah what the [ __ ] yeah there's that
many people collectively coming together
yeah yeah let's watch this [ __ ] yeah
love it powerful craziest feeling ever
and it's it's
it makes everything kind of worth it and
fun yeah it gives it it gives it meaning
you know yeah instead of just everybody
everybody can go to work you know
everybody can go to work and [ __ ] do
their thing but if there's something
deeper there than just [ __ ] getting
paid if there's an actual thing that's
happening like there's it's deeper it's
a deeper connection to it like it's an
actual thing artists right who paint
whatever [ __ ] they're going to paint
unless people like react to it a certain
way it's like it's just what is just
scribbles or something you know what i
mean 100
that's how it's interesting yeah that's
how i feel about
like when someone when i see someone
wearing a shirt in public in my own eyes
i still [ __ ] lose it yeah ever i've
passed by people like oh [ __ ] and it
blows my [ __ ] mind every time it's
always someone right like an older lady
wearing my [ __ ] wheelchair
yeah that was a nice one like i see why
you picked that one yeah and it's always
blows my mind like when pakinora's like
wow arkansas oh [ __ ] merced where i'm
from [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
it makes me stoke knowing that we have
that kind of like you know same with you
i can go anywhere in any state like no
we're going to be here you guys should
show up
and there's going to be a crowd because
they [ __ ] with you so heavy oh yeah yeah
i mean i had when we first launched i
had uh appearances at uh like the
different dispensaries right through
through coastal
and the amount of people that are
showing up to like 300 people [ __ ]
like massive amounts of people just
[ __ ] cycling
they'll bring some of them someone will
show up and like yo i don't smoke but
can you sign this and it'd be it'd be a
pack you know
yeah boom boom boom
i mean you can give out the please give
out the ingredients
you know don't hold on to that uh but
yeah it's it's uh it's it's humbling
more than anything right but at the same
time it's like you know like give
yourself some credit you are funny
how many videos
per week me
so now it's uh so my podcast goes live
once a week the award-winning podcast
the eavesdrop the easter egg what is
that eve strap eavesdropping that keeps
rubbing it's just it's a gaming podcast
where i interview
i just it's it's not a gaming podcast i
interviewed just internet personalities
i've interviewed about like two of the
cowboys i've uh josh hart has been on
there
uh and a million or
160 other people i can't believe i have
i have 160 episodes i think right
and only maybe there's been repeats
maybe only five times
oh so it's so i know stop people
different people which is what's [ __ ]
the fact that i know a hundred people
it's more than that the fact that i know
100 interesting enough people
it's [ __ ] mind-blowing you you got to
come on at some point let me i'll come
down here and i'll do it out here no no
i do it i do it from home right i do it
live but i'll come out here to do it
with you
yeah so yeah we'll do a special
we'll age restrict it
you can oh did you do that on your on
your own yeah restrict it yeah well no
you because we'll be smoking smoking oh
yeah yeah you and then you and then
we'll also do the pine park podcast
obviously oh [ __ ] so we'll do two which
will be more youtube oriented stuff
right and then we'll do the pine park
one where we can be ourselves our true
selves all right i'm with it anywhere
you know i get age streets no matter
where i'm at i've gone on other comedian
[ __ ] and got an age restricted so you
let me yeah just like hey this one
don't say the normal thing because i'm
trying to get to like normally man i'm
going to be honest i'm a pretty [ __ ]
animator i talk a shitload yeah but i
really want to learn more about you yeah
yeah so when i guess episodes i don't
really go as hard but usually i'm
[ __ ] throwing not for real yeah yeah
yeah so yeah i love going on other
people's shows because i get to go just
oh yeah you asked me [ __ ] all right one
[ __ ] time that's mine yeah so we'll
do two we'll do the gaming one so you
can do that but the pine park one
obviously more industry [ __ ] all right
cool cool cool so my very last question
wait we're leaving all right let's just
still get this oh well
how long we've been here yeah 145.
that's about right all right um i have a
question yeah
so
you have you're now fully
got optic back you bought it back which
is [ __ ] incredible which is hilarious
as hell they're like yeah yeah we'll
sell it to you we're [ __ ] it up
that's not what happened no that's what
i got from it i'm not you didn't say
that that's what i
i got um
you came back now you have this cannabis
business yeah right what's the next step
are you gonna somehow try to merge this
into a
weed centric weed friendly team
i don't i mean i'm i i'm i'm i i'm weed
friendly right like talking about like
yo you said the rams own the [ __ ]
gorillas yeah whatever
what do you have any plans of like
i don't know maybe there are some
serious gamers out there that have a
cannabis base following yeah
is there a team like that out there
that's weed
friendly
like in the weed leagues and [ __ ] like
that no like saying oh call of duty we
have today the [ __ ]
yeah los angeles or something something
yeah no not yet i mean i'm sure that in
the future there will be right like it's
inevitable that youtube continues to
sort of repeat and reinvent itself into
everything that it does uh i think where
where we're going is
more of a you know
we're we're cannabis company we're
flower company but at the same time
we're a media company like it's uh it's
not just this one thing we want to we
want to make sure that everything that's
been applicable before and all of the
businesses that i participated in have
the same
sort of uh path which is a an
entertainment media company that happens
to also sell flower
gaming and entertainment business that
also has happens to be really good at
esports so good that it's won 35
championships 34 more than 35 call of
duty championships
right so it's it's a media company that
happens to be really good at esports
it's a media company that
focuses on fishing it's a media company
that focuses on golf it's a media
company that has a flower business
attached to it conglomerate
yeah i mean it's like how much like how
can we make this more fun you know what
i mean that's that's my mentality always
how how can we create more to make
people want to spend some time with us
we not met you before this is [ __ ]
crazy this is a lot of what you've said
tonight yeah yeah yep it's almost like
you were like you guys are on like it's
[ __ ] weird huh yeah it's you you're
just in a different lane
because i always thought about what if i
did what i did and didn't have weed in
my hand what would i be doing right now
because it's so taint like taboo still
that i've been getting i've been doing
it
i've been doing
content this november will be a decade
that i started doing all this
and just two years ago i've recently
just like oh i can actually monetize
this
yeah
so
from
you know what i mean so from my
perspective i always thought like
it's a you it's it's a you like yo no
this is what i would have done if i
never had to get tainted with when i was
doing something else and i was doing i
always thought because advertising is my
[ __ ] i bet you but bro you're you're
you're 32 you said yeah bro
you got more than enough time to do all
of that oh
yeah yeah and you will yeah yeah i mean
from when i started yeah yeah yeah wow
cause you were doing it what
a little bit before like three four
years before i started doing this but
but imagine if if you would have seen
like that it's not just about this one
thing that your relationship with them
is so deep that you can go start your
own [ __ ] cooking show and they're
going to [ __ ] show up oh that's what
our whole yeah now it's like let's do
stuff that we like that the fans will
like but do it [ __ ] better than we
could ever yeah yeah yeah like we could
have just you know there's there's a lot
of podcasts out there that have a lot of
money and then and their background is
not even and
[ __ ] looks like [ __ ] and you you're
gonna say better example is you could
have just did season four story time
where we just set up the room instead
you completely reinvented yeah exactly
yeah because why because the fans are
gonna go oh yeah [ __ ] yeah and that's
the reaction i want because i always
imagine like looking through like
oh man that's like that's their reaction
oh where are they at they're at work and
i imagine people like oh i'm at work oh
i'm at school i'm at [ __ ] i'm jogging
and i'm listening to you so i always
think of like people's reactions like
how can we make it even cooler see but
you're thinking of your own reaction
that the reason that you're successful
is because you are so connected to what
you want to see as a fan
that you're creating those things
because you're like you're imagining
that defensively like oh my god and
guess what they are but because you as a
fan of of what you're living sorta is
putting out the the right sort of thing
and you'll never go wrong like over if
you the only time that you go that you
might go wrong with this if you
overthink something
yeah if you don't let your instincts get
i mean look where you're at dude like
[ __ ] it's because you understand you
understand this this connection and you
understand this connection you know what
i mean
big [ __ ] time yeah that's that that's
that's how we started doing it oh yeah
man
like i said
it's just i wouldn't want to be friends
with that person like
i do i would want to be friends with
that person
i am he's just not we just have never
met that's what we just that's our [ __ ]
we stand on my other channel like we're
the same [ __ ] we just haven't
met yet we would be friends we're just
we will meet one day
and that's the whole point in
it'll be brief
better not be well but it'll it'll be me
i'll have a fork
better not be while i'm eating but no
it'll it'll be short but it'll be
meaningful because it'll just be like
solidifying something that that's
it'll be materializing something that
has always been there which is the
relationship yeah and i just love it
dude i love because you know growing up
as a kid like seeing
superstars like i used to [ __ ] with
brett favre hey like wow could you break
far as my favorite quarterback of all
time get the [ __ ] out of here bro when
he won the quarterback challenge in 1997
off the of his back foot [ __ ]
i was 17 you know so it was easy for me
right and he [ __ ] bombed that [ __ ] i
was like that's my quarterback and the
fact that you should play quarterback
yeah well yeah i mean not
yeah that was my that's my position
position of choice none of my friends
could throw farther or more accurately
okay so i i pride myself on having an
amazing [ __ ] accurate arm and i
really really do it's kind of stupid i
try to be quarterback all growing up and
then you're [ __ ] fat like yeah but i
i just tried out um just ruined him and
they're like yeah but weigh you i used
to play city league like wait you're a
lineman
like all right next year same thing one
like but your family you [ __ ]
and then one day don't put your
limitations on them they know they give
me a yeah like come on i'll run them
over too
um
so brett favre was my [ __ ] growing up
but i have a long story he dissed the
[ __ ] out of me in public one no so he
hurts my heart my feelings and uh that's
a small child as a kid
bro that's wow i have his little toys
brett favre in my living room right now
yeah and still i always say [ __ ] brett
but god i love that far so [ __ ] much
he's like my favorite he's my favorite
i'm gonna tell you an athlete's story
and one of my favorite athletes of all
time shaquille o'neal
[ __ ] growing up shaq you know shaq
everything [ __ ] michael jordan first and
then my second favorite was shaquille
o'neal right years go by i'm an adult i
have optic it's 2013. we are at some
we're in rally north carolina somewhere
and there's a basketball golf convention
and i see charles barkley in front of me
and i'm like get the [ __ ] out so i i'm
30 you know 33 34. yeah 33 34 at that
time i go up to him like i'm like i'm in
charge i'm such a big fan can i get a
picture he said yeah for sure boom take
a picture with him i got it boom
i [ __ ] go and i see shaq
right this was like later on in the day
i look i look up because he's massive i
look up at him and i see him and i'm
like what the [ __ ] on my shot in the sun
video i'm like
can i picture can i get a picture he's
like not right now
right
and i was like i was like i was like
come on man really quickly really
quickly man really get a picture and
he's like he's like no no right now his
uh one of his security guards
you know goes over at me and says
not right now man like like annoyed and
i'm like now i know that i was you know
i i can see how i was being annoyed
because he said no already get the [ __ ]
away right um
but man i admired this dude right like
he was he was like you know blue chips
like i watched all his kazam and all
that [ __ ] i watched
i'm like when the [ __ ] else am i ever
ever going to get a chance to get a
picture and he said no and i was like
[ __ ] right so it's on youtube shaq this
is hacks
you know what i'm saying [ __ ] 300
thousand views
oh [ __ ] all right so this was 2013 right
you fast forward four years video game
awards 2017. optic is nominated for
esports team of the year oh we [ __ ]
win
guess who gives us the [ __ ] award
[ __ ]
shaq mother [ __ ]
right yeah so i go up there i [ __ ]
i'm like shocked and i go like this to
give him a hug
i give him a hug he grabs my ass
one hand both cheeks
he said boom and then he gives me the
award [ __ ] just my boys my boys are up
there with it's powerful yeah he's just
he's just a big dude no because i'm like
oh my hugged him he he did the joke
right i didn't say he you know he didn't
[ __ ] grope me but he
anyway
there's a little salt and pepper that
was put on top of that joke or that
story so
he gives us that so you know full circle
moment he he told me no
and then he gave me a [ __ ] award when
when he'd [ __ ] see that guy if i stay
shaq hey you dissed me one time no i
would never
i would never i would no no yeah sure
him was insignificant by bro i'm about
to do something yeah right now yeah yeah
of course it's shaq yeah yeah yeah that
and i understand it's in the middle of
lobby if i'm getting a picture he gotta
give everybody a picture
he's gonna make one dude happy and piss
everybody off now he's yeah no i get it
what a [ __ ] story i love that yeah
hopefully one day i'm like in line
somewhere and i go oh my god his [ __ ]
breath in front of me
what about guys smoke shack out during
tnt yes
did you see the espn thing where shaq
was like oh someone's smoking out here
and charles barking everybody in espn's
talking about someone smoking it up at
the laker game yeah
the next morning that was our guest oh
and he has the video but he has the
behind the scene video where he starts
talking [ __ ] to shaq because he's a kobe
like fanatic yeah and he's like yeah if
we would have won those other two
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] oh in his video
shaq turns and stares his ass down yeah
and then he hit marty i was like yo
someone told me shaq is actually looking
for me
and he was on the show
that's a big man yeah i mean i'm pretty
sure you gotta run shaq but
i'll dip under a truck that's right
if he wanted to put his hands on you he
would put his ass on i'm not gonna let
it happen yeah you what do you think i'm
not gonna roll under [ __ ] to get away
from chatting with your t-rex
and then he's next to a little puddle
and you see the vibrations
yo kazam
all right i'll just say that
when the hamburgers fell from the sky i
was like yo
wait what the [ __ ] you tama
hamburgers fell from the sky remember
when he wished for a bunch of junk food
or something and pizzas and hamburgers
were flopping that's all i was like i
was like where do you live
no that's the only part of that whole
movie i remember man
we got you some presents man oh yeah
let's see
thank you oh [ __ ]
there's some jars in there from uh from
our season two
season three season three a hoodie oh
thank you
oh my god oh it's these jars yeah these
are the best jars yeah i love these they
told me that if it's dark in there they
cure better
yeah you're not supposed to uh don't put
your weed in direct sunlight you leave
in your jar in the car on like on the
floorboard is the worst thing you could
ever do
don't do that
crypto chronic
[Music]
what crypto crawling yeah man
anyway you could uh if can i tell them
where people can get it
yeah
for stores yeah look if you're in
california you can get it delivered to
your house pintparkhq.com
uh if you go to deliver to your house oh
because it's i got you got you yeah wow
yeah it's nice right
look listen and you could you could get
it delivered to your house how
hq
you have your own delivery service which
says [ __ ] drones yo
are you [ __ ] with me on the drone
part maybe
uh yeah look it's try it out give it a
shot if you if you listen get that
chocolatine and play some [ __ ] elden
ring for nine hours oh this is a sick
package
oh i like that one i'm an artist man you
know i wanted to to i was modified mids
[ __ ]
photography [ __ ] art you know we
wanted to do
a little bit of everything
was the fear of god
shoes nah those are the 750s oh they
look like dc750 yeah i've only seen
those [ __ ] once because the
[ __ ]
boom boom boy i thought god
oh wow yo you guys did a very good job
on this thank you if you uh the cam
driver right that's my favorite just the
cab drivers yeah it's my favorite yeah
just period
it uh it affects my
my physiology differently i don't think
i said
no no it's good i i like to say big
words like photosynthesis photosynthesis
man i learned that one i think what was
it from uh that's that new plugin on
photoshop right no i forgot it here
that's good what was osmosis jones the
movie what's this you know you you
brought a lot of [ __ ] thank you so much
yeah you know just
so this is all at your pine park hq yeah
i mean i don't know if we have any more
of those but that you know just uh just
talking to my appreciation of saying
thank you man thank you
when i when i started looking to get
into this industry i do what i always do
with every other industry it's like who
are the movers and shakers in that
particular spot especially on youtube
because i think that youtube defines and
will continue to define culture period
uh and yours are one of the ones that
for i first came about uh and i started
watching she was good thank you [ __ ]
from one podcaster to another let's go
appreciate it [ __ ] yeah
what does it say pine paris
yeah what is pine park oh ellie kush
cake they cook by pine park yeah gosh is
that an actual place or does it park uh
it's
we used to smoke weed in a park that had
a lot of pines
you know i was like i'm the one i
consider myself a very creative person
what do you want to name your rebrand um
[Music]
everybody has a pine park you know what
i mean like that's why so
yeah to me it was more about like the
like
you know how
home is where the heart is
you know happy happiness is where your
weed is okay
pine park is that happiness all right
that's the motto this is the one for me
which one's item see
true cush breath yeah
oh because you like og yeah that no that
smells really good so being so straight
edge kind of for way longer than all of
our other guests basically do you [ __ ]
with like dad shrooms do you go further
into it so yesterday because i was
hanging out with uh with erican and tim
all day i was i did i did dab so i did
my first man let's let's say i've maybe
dabbed [ __ ] ten times in my life
let's just say okay
my uh my first three times were with
skelly
at 7 10 labs
he got high
yeah i mean it was it was a different
kind of high though it was like uh i
didn't feel
like a fresh coaster yes uh yes 710 has
like a
their flavors are not as heavy i feel
they're a little more like
like refreshing more they hit the they
were more they were more asmr
yeah they were more as mister you know
yes yeah so so i i was i was uh i was
dabbing yesterday
you know what i mean
yeah yeah water
that's what yeah
little kids talk about dabbing and [ __ ]
like have no idea where they're shaking
from
jesus all right thank you yeah so this
is a lot of weeds yeah thank you so much
give it a shot you know it's uh yeah
we're gonna give it a shot it's weed
you know what i'm saying like not for
for me nowadays like obviously you can
tell you know
you can tell high quality weed and you
can say like artisan weed obviously
the artisan weed i like how you're not
being like a [ __ ] connoisseur about
it you're like check it out you're gonna
[ __ ] like it yeah don't you know what
my my i don't complicate things yeah
no i'm not gonna try to something smart
yeah that's how i am with the two like
does this [ __ ] scare me or not yeah
[ __ ]
scare me yeah whether or not yeah so
so yeah it's uh it's good i get high
let's go i get high all the time uh-huh
that was the styles p quote right thank
you
marty of course martin he's come from
that now where do you stand with music
are you into like 90s hip-hop shot yes
strictly yeah look i'm a graffiti writer
what same
yeah he will not change the station well
he's listening the same like 12 cds back
to back to back from his life
i'm heavy on the like as far as new york
[ __ ] goes jadakiss jay-z
nas all those i'm real big into nipsey
i'm big into you know
yeah that generation of music too but
wu-tang clan for me has always been like
everything for as far as music goes but
like i got super like underground my
favorite artist a stop rock not to be
confused with oh no asap rock you're
talking about like with [ __ ] slug and
yeah living legends i know exactly
you're talking about when they said
rocky came out with
hey
i like asap rocky a lot i went hey you
know asap
brock yeah is around right
no he didn't i didn't i don't he had to
have known bro you think that's a big
[ __ ] and they have their own asap
group of course he's not gonna be like
i'm not changing when he goes google
himself this fool's gonna start popping
up first right no it's spelled it's
spelled different but it's so aesop
it's so dead on jadakiss
jadakiss
it's so dead similar but you're like oh
it means two different things yeah okay
never mind
but it's when i heard it the first time
aesop rock's your favorite yeah uh what
album did he put out he put out a i
bought it it was like uh
he had like different artists on it it
was a bunch of instrumentals he [ __ ]
made
and then
i have it on cd what does it look like
it's green with a white like tag writing
on it
i could be misremembering this [ __ ] but
i have a pretty extensive really good
memory i don't know because i i i don't
even i stopped literally at one my brain
said this is what you like
and that's it i did open i did expand my
my horizons a little bit uh like with
mac miller through nate chad who was
like if i'm if you're hanging out with
people
like their music is gonna infiltrate
yours the same that hope you would hope
yours did mine didn't but anyway uh he's
just you know he likes that underwater
rap [ __ ] you know what i mean that's not
my kind of thing uh-huh the underwater
rap [ __ ] i'm autotune yeah you know
underwater wraps
yeah that was a real genre
it's all you know it's hip-hop hip-hop
to me you know what i mean i love that
that was the best [ __ ] so like
forever 36 chambers that's all your [ __ ]
that's my [ __ ] yeah i just met rayquan
for the first time ever
had dinner with him oh that's a good one
yeah oh you're [ __ ] kidding me with
the chef bro it was it was it was
[ __ ] i i get there right now and i
went with uh one of my one of my closest
friends is this dude named omens but
don't [ __ ] embarrass me in front of
the chef you know that's what i said
that's his nickname and uh and you know
i'm sitting playing it cool right we
were having a business meeting talking
about business things and
uh
we started talking and then he's like
well you know hector has been you know
listening to your music all the time and
it's cool i play out and underplayed it
to do that introduce us and i'm like
listen man i'm a full disclaimer right
now i'm a [ __ ] massive fan of yours
and he's like oh thank you man respect
them i don't think you get there's a
[ __ ] purple tape in my coat pocket
right now
that i'm hoping that you're going to
sign at one point tonight and he's like
pull it out right now and i was like
nice
and then he signed it and [ __ ] but yeah
it was like it was like meeting batman
yeah it's one of those moments man it
was meeting batman i was like
[ __ ] god i could not believe it i just
sat in the center in disbelief to this
to this very i'm having a really good
year i'm not even going to talk about it
because that's how good it's going
you know what i mean i got optic back
won a championship recently let's go you
know i'm saying we're we're we're
we're as popular as ever the relation
with the green wall is good and i met
rayquan
good [ __ ]
perfect time for that [ __ ]
see that's what i was hoping my favorite
interaction was going to be yeah like yo
you know what kid you look like you have
an arm maybe you should play back up
like oh [ __ ] you know i was just hoping
for that
just for that [ __ ] uh you know what
i'm saying instead i just hit
i'm hoping he was on pills that day um
that's what i hope nice breath you want
a nice breath i wanna i'm just hoping
i hope that was the
excuse he had a killed outbreak oh and
that's why he dissed me so hard yeah but
i waited outside the frisco game for him
and they won so i was like it's not that
they lost bubba frank's took a picture
donald driver took a picture of me i was
so hyped bro i was in the tunnel
i was waiting outside for like two and a
half three hours in the reign of san
francisco so it was not like it wasn't
cold it was freezing i had my cheese
head on i had a farm jersey on
and this is an enemy territory bro yeah
and my grandpa's a niner fan and he
brought me because i'm not sitting in
the rain for brett favre and i'll beat
the truck i like brett farve and i lived
in chicago i'm in [ __ ] california my
everybody's a niner a raider fan you
know what it's like wearing a package
it's not what it's like it is it's not
what it's like with the relationship
between the [ __ ] jesus and the
[ __ ] bears well niners packers is not
as strong as yeah exactly so yeah i was
a brett park fan
and i'm like you know i'm like i don't
speak english
get this [ __ ] kid that's what
happened no
no
oh my god dude i was like i don't like
him no more i'm just kidding
but yeah that's what happened oh anyway
these two old ladies had signs waited
for two and a half three hours in the
rain i mean rain yeah and they had a
song they were chanting they made up
about brett favre i was like yo you guys
really made a whole song
and he walked by we're like oh [ __ ] yeah
the bowl cut brett favre like a little
shitty haircut the two ladies are like
brick break brett let me suck you up no
they're old as [ __ ] and they tell them
what they don't
these two old ladies are so cool
and he's straight up he's eight feet
from us
from the tunnel to the bus
there's a 50 yards and this [ __ ]
says this the whole time and will he had
his headphones on no there's no
headphones there wasn't ear buds i'm
staring i'm like yo brett favre
oh my [ __ ] god i'm like
and he just
yep
that's exactly crickets
that's what i got from him and he went
and the only went
and he looked at me i looked at them
and i [ __ ] arrested development sad
walk
all the way back to my grandpa's car and
had to tell him what happened
should have been a niner fan no he's
what he told me should have been a
knight
but look at but look at the happiness
your sadness just brought it
up
it's all worth it it was worth it
because one day brett favre mm-hmm
i'm going to tell this journey or
he's gonna be sitting here smoking weed
because he launched his own brand no he
didn't no i'm saying he looked at me
everyone's gonna do it but even if it's
trash i still want to smoke yeah
like one day
what would you call it
your brand
if i'm brett favre wonder why
that would have been perfect [ __ ] that's
already taken what do we call it
wonder brett
brent
varve don't know i'll get i mean that's
hard yeah
so you now you get watched a heavy duty
pain pillow
now you see [ __ ] how hard it is
[Laughter]
my dad's garage
all right that was [ __ ] incredible
brett favre you off the hook i don't
know what to call your [ __ ] wii
company but you're making levi
commercials and [ __ ] so
uh wrangler or wrangler i'll [ __ ] it
then everybody call yourself a fan real
fan call yourself a fan real fan brett
no ass looks great in the host
them chaps hey man one day one day we'll
see while we do uh i have we have a
guest coming on next week that i'm i was
a big football guy but we have a our
first nfl player coming next week
and i'm [ __ ] who's it
ricky [ __ ] oh we could say it
okay it's ricky greek regularly he's
is it ricky williams from ballers or the
real ricky williams or what's up
who's ricky and ballers
you guys watch ballers i only watched
like the first like five
just go watch all of it yeah it's so
[ __ ] up no no i got to where he's like
losing his license yeah the same week i
went past that that's where i stopped
season one
so we had we had uh uh we had vernon
from ballers on on the pine power
podcast oh [ __ ] it's super super cool
yeah but there's this uh the main dude
denzel washington's son in real life
yeah his name is ricky
something in the show he's there
it might be ricky williams i don't know
but [ __ ] rick is in real
as a [ __ ] kid
i remember ricky williams i'm like damn
man and now he's going to be here i
can't wait like like you i may or may
not have your rookie yo
dance yeah it's a ps10 it's been oh it i
have it in my case i was a big collector
as a kid were you oh yeah i got some
have you flipped anything no but i i'm
sitting on the tom brady rookie mint
condition i found the other day and i
didn't know fine i'll give you five
grand for it
[Music]
i need a slight nice honda for it
for brand new though brand new honda not
these rig flippers
um
so pine park you can get it at uh pine
park h2.com all right yeah and it's not
in stores and then anywhere else yeah
it's a source across across uh l.a okay
cool so yeah just in case people you can
go to columba right common what else
coastal coastal's uh the one where we
had the uh the meetups nice yeah yeah
try the camera stores try the cam
drivers my favorite
i don't know why but it is does
something to my
my breath
yeah and season three is available you
can get the apple fritter season three
is available yeah season three is
available right now uh there's some
season two season one uh i don't think
there's a lot of season one left but if
you can find a camp driver you should
[ __ ] try it or the camera reserve but
cam driver is mine uh yeah it's
uh apple fritter apple uh apple fritter
we have ellie kush cake uh we have uh
uh
[ __ ] i have i've been smoking weed uh
apple fritter uh early kush cake
uh kryptochronic which is oh the ones
delicious because the christmas chronic
when i opened it looks like fritter it's
the first thing i thought but it's not
the fridge okay peanut butter breath
uh we
had to
label it peanut butter hex because we
have two different peanut butter breaths
i know there's a people don't like that
and i get it
my bad but at the same time like it's
peanut butter breath underneath it it's
like because we grew that at our
facility while the other one was grown
at uh at waverider which at least you're
being transparent is [ __ ] about it oh
yeah you know again i'm i'm trying to
put the highlight on the on the on the
farmers because you know by the time
that it leaves like you never know who
the artist is and you should know who
you know
something this
meaningful right because it's not just
it's not just a piece of lettuce it's
not tomato that you you know it's it's
it's your morning tea it's of sorts
right there's there's a certain level of
relationship there that you want to know
you know who the artist is you want to
know what how they feel about marijuana
and what they see it as
and when it's a passion project it
becomes a little bit more than anything
so
uh jason is the one that manages and
operates ours and he does a killer job i
think
i love that
i never really thought about it like
that yeah i mean all credits should go
to to the you know to the farm it's
their final touch on it like i would
never want somebody else to really edit
the podcast because it's got my touch on
it they're the chef i mean they're
preparing something for you that's gonna
take it's gonna taste different
one month to the next and it's gonna be
good for a long time if it's if it's
that good
yeah makes sense no i like it or maybe i
just made all that [ __ ] up
yeah just the reoccurring themes like by
the way my name's not even hectic you
know what
the team optic that i saw it doesn't
exist yeah this is one big freestyle
guys i mean you're all high
yo the guy that we booking agent
it's me
i did this
you know those [ __ ] 90 people that
were like spamming you can't hack
someone that was [ __ ] me gotcha
get [ __ ] cop
i have 90 max just open that's how i get
on podcasts
that'd be [ __ ] incredible oh my god
don't you think people like that oh my
god you just opened up like we gotta
[ __ ] hire a guy there yeah
you guys didn't notice how i capitalized
the e
that's my signature
remember the zodiac killer that's you
that's my signature i've gotten the
award show shaq i'm i'm i'm i'm the
farmer's almanac killer
the wet bandits of this [ __ ] the wet
band it's the farmer's almond that
killer what's happening well you know
what's happening
it's not pine pirates it's that way it's
that time of the podcast
when i come out here bro to film the
podcasts now
mind you okay i don't smoke weed right
on the regular because i can't yeah all
right so if i'm at a party or if i'm
somewhere and someone has to boom
awesome i'm [ __ ] thank god you were
sent by god anyway
when i come out here to record these
[ __ ] things i do four podcasts in a
row
so i'll be smoking for four hours
straight sometimes like fresh like just
[ __ ] nothing
you know what i mean so i'm like i'm
like my tolerance is not what it is
the fourth one is just a [ __ ] blur
because i trained a lot yesterday with
[ __ ] eric and tim
they would they did not
we did not stop smoking
the whole time i'm like god damn
so
i believe it my tolerance california man
yeah once you get out here it's like oh
yeah i drink water yeah i smoke weed
yeah like every [ __ ] couple minutes
spoiled it is truly like that's why i
don't really like to travel too much
where what's date
go to jail over there i'm good
yeah i don't really have i don't see a
point until it's a business thing yeah
that's just for me because like texas
like you're like i can't smell it oh
i'd have to move yeah give me can i can
i pay for a license
why not real can i pay for
how much is the license
i'll pay the license new mexico i think
just got recreational yeah yeah yeah
yeah my homie literally bought a place
there just to go there because he's from
texas like dude i don't get in trouble
here yeah it's only [ __ ] three hours
i have to go to oklahoma city to or
oklahoma how far is that from it's like
an hour
man my geography skills are not [ __ ]
doing me justice right now i thought i
was pretty good for
an hour
[ __ ] or maybe i just made that [ __ ]
uh-huh
no it's like it's like it's definitely
an hour it's like an hour and a half
it's definitely i know for sure how
[ __ ] far it is
100
um so do me a favor just tell us where
everybody can find you at yeah you know
just uh you can find me on twitter at
hex
h3cc
with the three e backwards and at pine
park on twitter also what about
instagrams instagram's the same thing uh
h ecz on that one we got we were able to
pay for that one the other one somebody
had it some [ __ ] dude has it and the
thing is
it's like i was
if if somebody doesn't use an account
for two years and they're squatting on
it you can make a petition four years
for me and has someone used it for on 20
000 posts of 2000 yeah but does i mean
he's not logging in to see he's just not
a poster if he's using his account you
it's not considered squatting because
you can open an account and not
participate
uh as you posting but you can
participate as you reading so
yeah so that's what that's what uh
that's how it goes so i was able to get
those way hacks at pine park yeah of
course oh [ __ ] of course
you gotta start asking you know what i
mean well i think it's different than
the wii world everybody's like i don't
know [ __ ] can you pay somebody
so i don't know
the biggest nicest rule breakers in the
world you know what i mean like you
should ask you know what i mean
just give it a shot it's it's a new
because of the sacrifice that everybody
has done up until this point like it's
at a different point now where you can
you can start the discussion we're just
like don't delete us don't don't that's
how we do that's how we do we don't ask
it's like yo please just let us stay
because we get played so much like what
are we doing wrong yeah so you don't
want to make any noise yes we don't
that's why i don't position you to get
my channel but just imagine if you're
able if you have a contact that you too
and that understands that you know what
you're doing and they see it
they're going to be willing to be like
well you're not really [ __ ] breaking
anything here yeah no this we wanted a
space to be completely mainstream with
us yeah like how rogan was when he
started for everybody yeah of course the
weed we was the you know heavy duty in
rogan early youtube days it wasn't a
[ __ ] problem yeah yeah but it's also
joe wrote it's different when you're
just a [ __ ] guy that literally talks
about selling packs his whole life
because i think i feel like is it
because i'm explicit is it because of
this but you're saying no bro it's
google they're not looking at you like
that yeah it also might have to do with
your demographic you know maybe if they
deem it's like it's reaching a lot of
mega young people
that's with anything any person can type
anything though yeah i know you know so
it's not like what do you want me to do
yeah well that's what i'm saying like if
you ask and be like yo what really
happened or what was the real reason
they'll i'm i'm sure they can't work
around i'll connect you to one of my
boys that's the whole point they're in
the gaming side but i'm sure that they
can connect with the right people
because i they did the same thing to uh
to my fishing buddies who are also
hunters like they would get demonetized
because they were they were wilding out
showing [ __ ] skinning [ __ ]
you know there's a lot of blood in that
[ __ ] some people don't want to see that
you know if you're
an advertiser let's call it i don't know
coca-cola maybe you don't want your [ __ ]
next to uh you know that sort of thing
so again it's not the platform as much
as it is the people that are paying to
be put in front of people yeah right
because sometimes it's just awareness
right so for us like there might be a
brand that you don't use but you see us
like oh i could use that and then you're
just raising awareness for that right
they they look for that
advertisement too but then we get
demonetized for that and i put them in
contact with my people and then they
were able to finally sort of align good
enough to where everybody's following
the rules and they're on the same page
let's go yeah oh [ __ ] need man just
tell me what to do tell me what not to
do
but did you actually you haven't really
actually asked them though no i'm so
[ __ ] afraid to even rebuttal of
anything
i'm telling you man
we're doing this yeah listen they're
californians the people working there
are californians that's what i don't get
that's what i'm saying so they like the
conversation's not gonna go but with me
it's a little different like we said
earlier i've been deleted so many times
on every platform except for twitter
every platform vin milk or
vimeo
vimeo yeah they they deleted me yeah i
was like yo there's rappers and [ __ ]
they did you okay with the [ __ ] you
don't have vimeo man they did you a
favor no we had no we had it to back up
for our site like oh
now we had to do our own like oh we
thought it was okay yeah like no [ __ ]
you
so yeah i mean snapchat deleted me
but we're much more legitimate now read
isn't so big and scary and this is just
a crossover show yeah this show is
different we like that was the most
we've probably ever seen on the show
right there
oh yeah it's actually the only time i
think except for maybe like oh gee we
we really barely ever even busted out
like that at all yeah just because we're
like youtube they don't like that [ __ ]
i don't know but
we'll see we'll see where we're at but i
appreciate it thank you for that because
that's a big help sure um so everything
you said hex and then pine park pine
park hq that's where you got everything
yeah yeah why do you got anything else
yeah and if you like call of duty only
support optic
that was a stern warning but how do you
how do you support a team uh who's your
favorite uh basketball team
i don't watch basketball okay football
packers okay there you go
how do you support the pack i mean
watching them yeah how do you
watch
on youtube twitch anything that's live
oh god can you watch the tournaments oh
yeah we just had a tournament yeah you
can fans can watch it happen yeah so
i'll give you an example when we won our
championship uh
five weekends ago for
a couple of last month when we were when
we won our championship
we wanted in our stadium
in front of i believe like 1900 people
there and live in attendance you can if
you go to my insta you can see a picture
of me in the fame i saw that picture
that was the game that was yeah that's
where we won and there was a hundred and
like eighty thousand people watching
online
on youtube if it was that should have
been on twitch it would have been way
more yo i didn't know it was like that
you could watch this
that many people were live watching you
guys play [ __ ] games and win yeah
insane
yeah i didn't know it was like this
look how many people it is it feels like
a movie and guess what
we needed a big we could if we if we if
we had a bigger space
we would have filled that [ __ ] out too
at wind trust arena in chicago we sold 3
500 tickets
and we were and this was within the
first like within the first week of
announcing that chat it was we didn't
even let it develop to the time it got
cancelled because of covid but if we let
it go like we would have sold
way more than that
no [ __ ] people can i see why it's such a
big industry now because now you're like
oh that's my brett favre
he's on this team yeah wow but way more
handsome
you guys sell jerseys and [ __ ] yeah oh
we still that we sell out of jerseys
excuse me sell out oh jerseys
instantly yeah can you can you i gotta
see what this jersey looks like a gaming
jersey
right there that right there yeah not
not the one to the left of that girl
speaking of wish
right there
it's like it says coming soon wow
yo no way you guys are really oh i bet
you people love that [ __ ]
that's the optic texas one the optic one
also also says optic gaming and then our
team and the cdo's optic texas
call of duty league oh straight up says
that [ __ ] oh yeah wow man you guys
really opened my eyes up i didn't like i
said until like a month and a half ago i
had no idea yeah and then i didn't know
you could watch it that would be in fun
as [ __ ] oh you can watch yeah bro you
show up bro like people are like [ __ ]
yelling like oh
loud as [ __ ] bro you hear it it shakes
the [ __ ] everything shakes around you
it's that loud
that's amazing that's insane that sounds
fun as [ __ ] actually yeah it it's bro
it's it's it's insanity
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna show you a
video off of uh once we get off but it's
[ __ ] crazy that's sick okay so um so
how can i follow youtube it's just optic
gaming youtube yeah i have to give me
minus hacks uh and also pine park
obviously that's where i do that yeah so
the content that we're creating
uh in the cannabis industry is on pine
park and then sometimes i promote
like that through my channel but i also
have to be precautious of you know
obviously right you have to so
until everything gets figured out and it
you know patience is key then you know
we'll continue to do that that way but
that's my channel almost almost at a
million
but i've been i've been doing this for
like [ __ ] 10 years and my
inconsistency
has led me to this place right here
like [ __ ] man people hit a million super
super easy yeah you have to be this
consistent tv show like oh i know what
day and what time it's yeah i've logged
every single day for two years
uh minus give it say ten days in those
two year periods yeah when you become a
part of somebody's routine if they're
having breakfast with me
every single day and i don't show up one
of the days that's you know because you
vlog like people yeah what the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] always compared to what if the
simpsons didn't come on after football
on sunday oh you'd be [ __ ] heated
yeah yeah yeah they're they're they're
invested you know so it's good it's a
good thing to have all right so optic
gaming on youtube hex on youtube yeah i
think we covered all the places to find
them on yeah yeah yeah
only okay only
support optic game
spell it right [ __ ] thank you
so much for being here bro thank you for
the invite man thank you i'm really exci
i'm really happy to help you yeah i i'm
like you know you see me in a person
like uh or before you mean like i hope
i hope they're cool i hope they're nice
and i hope they're at least open-minded
i'm glad man you're like the texas
counterpart to yeah
because what you're saying is what we
preach a lot the overall message of we
have the opportunity to be entrepreneurs
more than anybody before yep that's
that's what we talk about non-stop it's
you have the opportunity because a lot
of people are stuck
but they just got to find it and it's
like it'll it'll happen turn your
hobbies into jobbies
okay or work for the [ __ ] man and be
miserable is your [ __ ] choice or if
you like it it's okay you're either
going to be a rule
maker or a rule breaker
okay
don't follow it don't follow break
drop yeah
i need a mic drop sound effect for
moments like that just just do this
all right man thank you so much thank
you for being with us for having me all
right guys this has been another episode
of the dope usual pod i'm [ __ ] high
this has been another episode have a
dope ass day damn i'm
fairly high yeah yeah
good all right do you hit bongs
[Music]